all right and we are live welcome to the
last word episode number 121. it's
another glorious Friday it'll be back in
front of the campfire for some more
looted shooter discussion I'm extremely
excited about our returning yes so we go
get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord who is not
only an awesome supporter and friend to
the campfire but was highly instrumental
in sparking a flash point into having
the last word
whether it be experience in game
development passion for the destiny
franchise or thought-provoking articles
his unique skill set is truly impactful
in our Gaming Community
introducing the developer and game
designer of adios and paratopic and a
freelance games rider for kataku us and
PC Gamer one of the most passionate
Destiny hunters in the game and our
favorite shotgun scientist
live from Kansas and making his return
at the campfire of the last word mommy
Lord doc Squiddy how we doing sir I am
alive holy [__] that's like the best
intro I've ever heard
royalty baby gotta do it right man
welcome back
that was even better than last time
cognito's had some practice he's been
stepping up his game man
look you were here where we had we were
Flashpoint you know what I'm saying we
had that you know that that studio
apartment we was just getting our stuff
together you know what I'm saying like
look what we did we got the studio the
bathroom was it was in the kitchen
basically you could cook while you go to
the bathroom it was closing listen man
we had the Chinese food on the floor we
was getting started episode four that's
when you was here episode four that is
crazy holy crap that was a while ago
2018 brother
the curse of Osiris
I was so happy this is Fresh Off The I
believe you're us gamer article yes and
that was that was an awesome article it
was awesome it went completely viral you
broke Reddit just for everybody who
don't know we're gonna let you introduce
yourself I'm just gonna let you know
what you know last thing that you did
when you were here and it was uh I
believe it was uh what was it uh how
Destiny 2 failed its fan base and this
was in the double primary double primary
era slow ability recharge era before go
fast you were here and you you had a
passionate article that really spoke to
the core and everybody rallied behind
you so enough about that tell the people
who don't know about you who you are
who's the doc what you do oh man okay uh
it's always you know one of the weird
things right trying to introduce myself
um
I'm just a dude who used to comment on
articles online
um
all right awesome let's get into it I I
um gosh I don't know I
I I kind of started arguing with people
online you know like they would they
would post things and I'd break them
down sentence by sentence and I learned
a habit of like oh okay I know how to
like start building ideas really simply
right so one day
um
they have this community thing on Kotaku
where they they post like Community
posts the front page or at least they
used to and uh I I wrote Steven sotillo
and I said look you put my stuff
on
you know the uh you put my stuff on like
the the
front page before so you think of front
page material why don't you you know
let's let's make it official why don't
you pay me right yeah let's go let's
like no no not quite like you know in
the hosta way but like why don't we why
don't you you know start um
take it be serious
out here I'm moving I'm shaking let's go
we do we doing things
he hired me for a while you know and and
I you know I just started breaking my
own games I try to do it like in a
simple and like useful way right because
like I figure
you know a lot of people who write about
video games they kind of talk down to
people right right me I want it to be
like okay I think everybody who's here
is interested in games
so
let's you know let's talk about that
right let's uh
let's try to help people who want to
know about games know more about games
and so that eventually led to you know
me getting gigs at other places IGN us
gamer you know all sorts of other sites
right in US gamer those guys are the
best I mean I think I've loved working
with them more than anybody else in part
because uh one of the one of the editors
I have there
um you know I was writing a piece
and uh
she was like isn't this a little long
like I'm not sure people will stick with
it I said like trust me I've done this
before like just trust me and you'll get
Good Hits and uh that Zelda piece I
think ended up being one of the the best
traffic pieces on the site and the fact
that she was willing to trust me and she
was like okay I'll trust your judgment
on this
um that made me more willing you know to
trust her judgment right in the in the
future and she's just that's what you
want in an editor is like this trusting
relationship right so I used to just
write all the time but
um
I
don't
I don't know how to put this
I'm very picky when it comes to games
right I know a lot of people they're
like hey if I had fun I had fun me I'm
like look games can be better games can
absolutely be better than this so
I don't really like walking Sims and uh
I wrote a piece about it and my editor
loved it and then his boss hated it so
he spiked it and I was like oh I'm gonna
show you buddy and uh you know I went
and I made an award-winning walking Sim
um and now I'm working on a new one but
you know in the first walking Sim it was
like
you know I don't like the games we just
walk around and don't do anything so I
went with lots of verbs Right video game
things you do or verbs so
um you know I was like I want to go you
know taking pictures I want to talk to
people I want to drive cars let's put
all that in a walking Sim framework so I
did that my next game is you know
what happens if you spend time on a farm
hanging around
um
yeah so that you know that's that's kind
of where I'm
kind of trying to advance my ideas you
know like how can we make first person
games more interesting how can we make
spaces to feel alive to feel rich
vibrant that's what I'm doing on my end
but you know I'm also a random dude from
the middle of Kansas right so it's not
like I can just you know March over to
Activision and be like you know how you
gave Bungie half a billion dollars to
make new IP give that to me I'll do the
same thing you all matter you don't
matter right now you're about to you're
about to make an average yeah yeah I'm
you know I'm trying to convince people
like hey I'm doing something uh
you know I'm doing something hopefully
unique and interesting I had a friend he
told me you know Alfred Hitchcock said
after Steven Spielberg uh movies would
never be the same like he destroyed the
concept of of filmmaking and remade it
into something fascinating this was
after Jaws right yeah I want to do that
I want to be for games with Steven
Spielberg was for movies right let's go
not that I want to make stuff like
Spielberg but I want to destroy what
came before so we can build better games
this is what I'm told I'm tired
I'm tired of playing games that are
predictable
I hear you know I hear you that changes
I'm sorry continue
I was just gonna say but I for me
I want games to be the best I can be
like I've written a lot of a lot of
stuff about Destiny it's probably not
super positive right like I wrote about
Vice and I was like what is happening
with Destiny now like why you know why
my 60 person Clan fall apart right like
what is going on and you know I never
want to like be negative the you know
there are a lot of dudes who are like I
remember some famous YouTuber guy being
like yeah well you know the positive
stuff never gets any hits so I only do
the negative stuff and it's like okay
well you know I try to do my best with
as much positivity as possible but
Destiny it's like I want it to be better
and they keep making weird decisions
right so I'm always I'm always worried
people like you just want to tear Dusty
down it's like not really it's my most
played video game of all time for a
reason
no it comes from a place of passion
right right it comes from a place of
passion it you know when you love
something you're not afraid to to be
critical but at the same time respect
I'll let you go you're just about to
jump in I was literally gonna say the
same thing you were is because
Destiny's in a weird place because we've
always all for literally six years now
seen the potential of this game be it
the franchise in Destiny one we get to a
point like rise of iron and we have
those cool armor sets and we're like oh
what's going on in D2 but it's always
the potential is there when they drop
things like the prophecy dungeon you see
it for the first time and the oryx
moment when you're in the bigger like
there are the game has such but and it's
always felt and the shooting has always
been like Second To None basically so
there are pieces about the game and the
potential is there and then so many
people have come from different
backgrounds whether it be like Call of
Duty and shooters or World of Warcraft
and RPGs and they're like I want to meld
this thing together and these things
don't go together but I really want them
to be this like perfect mesh of in my
head what could be greatness and I mean
as doc said it's like there are some
weird decisions that happen along the
way for for business for trying to bring
a bigger audience in for trying to go
RPG or not there's and it's been a bumpy
road along the way and we still are
stuck with this thing because for one
the community is amazing and been also
Second To None because I don't know of a
community that's like this for a game
and two
it's truly this thing that I mean it's
been six years of I'm a 37 year old and
it's been six years so it's like you
know close to one sixth of my life at
this point I've been covering and hyped
and do a YouTube channel and a podcast
and everything else over this thing so
it's like no it's it's a very unique
beast and we always just want we always
want more which is not fair to ask but
we do
one of my one of my hypest moments in
Destiny was uh you know other than like
say killing oryx I was walking through
the tower and and I ran across you at
bontus like I just saw you in the dark I
remember that I was like almost he
glistening was he glowing was he was the
aura was the sunlight
not no God race God calm down what was
the visual
Majestic obviously but you know also
clearly uh you know talking to the
postmaster as we all do yeah I know
about that I know about that I've
definitely been tweeted and being like
dude turn around I get to it like 30
minutes later sorry did you pull out the
Sophie Emoji did you did
no no I've definitely been called out on
Twitter by staring at either postmaster
or gunsmith and it's like it could be
one of those where I'm like oh it's just
like left the game for like 30 minutes
and Twitter could have exploded and I'm
like yep sorry
hilarious hilarious that's good that's
what it is one of your your movements
any other high points there and uh in in
Destiny history
besides me that's that's hard to top wow
I'm no oh God calm down
I'm just a dude playing games over here
man I that game has given me so much but
you know you said something about
you know a lot of reasons why there
there can be you know decisions made
like that I think I think I get some of
them you know I think a lot of people
they they go oh is bungee just greedy or
you know are they stupid or whatever I
don't think Bungie's greedy or stupid I
think they're
I think they're doing conventional
wisdom mixed with uh broken technology
um you know like uh of course uh what's
that guy asked to cross yep I think made
that video saying Hey the tech is bad
and they're gonna take those planets out
and they're gonna bring them back and
make them better a programmer buddy of
mine
he said what it looks like is happening
is it's not about storage on our end
they don't care about that like I mean
you know who who does right Call of Duty
is 300 400 500 gigabytes right you know
I have on my computer I have games that
are bigger than Destiny right now I got
Red Dead Redemption at like 100
something gigabytes I got Hitman 2 at
150 like that doesn't really matter for
us but when you build a game
when you build a game at home like I
have this on my computer like I build
for the Xbox that I've got here special
you know magical dev kit I'm not
supposed to talk about much
um you know when I'm building for that
like I click a button and my computer
like grinds to a halt as it tries to
generate all the files and that can take
a long time right so my buddy said what
he thinks is happening is the game
they're actually running into an issue
where when they try to build the game
and that means rebuilding every planet
every objective everything when they hit
that
they hit a limit and they're not able to
build the whole thing so they're
actually taking stuff out he thinks so
that they can actually ship the game
um because it won't like it probably
runs into some sort of error and when I
was like are you talking about literally
like compile type like that yeah yes
yeah when you're um like just getting
lighting to work in a game takes forever
because you have to make like click a
button and suddenly it's like all right
let's calculate all these you know all
this lighting and stuff of course Bungie
is great lighting you know and I I don't
have any inside inside knowledge into
their Tech I mean I have a little bit
but like it's not it's not enough to to
say anything about but it's like yeah I
could see that being an issue the
problem is as a consumer a every MMO I
play is bigger than this you know but
like Destiny is the smallest MMO in the
world right you know I can Guild Wars 2
I haven't even finished the first area
it's huge it's bigger than all of death
it means okay maybe that's not entirely
true but it's oh no I played the
continents of World of Warcraft were I
mean yeah they dwarf it so I mean you're
talking about different levels of detail
and stuff but no just like the scale of
the destinations no yeah there there are
games that destroy this one in size
Fidelity would be a different comparison
too I would say even objectives right
like I can go log into like a week of
Warframe and do completely unique things
every night and Destiny can't do it like
you log in and you're like I'm gonna do
these bounties and they're gonna refresh
every day and there's I think I counted
at one point like 60 daily bounties wow
it was something absurd like that
includes every planetary vendor you know
people you probably don't grind every
day but it was like
at what point is this game eating up too
much of my life for very little reward
and I was thinking about that it was
I've been getting kind of bombed you
know I'm at a point where basically
nobody in my clan plays anymore and of
course all that comes to the uh the
expiration dates on the guns right
right so so let's get to it let's get
right to it so um sure you now give me
in with your clan right you said that
they've tapered off like uh what are the
reasonings you're getting back from your
hardcore Clan as to why they're putting
the game down and then I see you alluded
to Sun setting which has been highly
contentious at one point but uh that
last word between me and e but um
where's your stance on that also
so everybody in the clan
um really started dropping off I was on
my way to Pax actually when this
happened you know they mentioned sun
setting
um
that was when people really started to
go okay we're done the fomo had caused a
lot of people to burn out like just
having a push like I had a friend she
got into it she was like oh man I love
this season like this was uh you know
Destiny is an amazing game there's so
much to do that she got into it with uh
which promised the dark below okay the
latest the the big DLC right the last
Shadow keep Shadow
it's like 8 30 in the morning here I'm a
little tired
yeah so she she got into it she was like
oh my God this is incredible but then
she wanted the seal and so she grinded
really really hard for that and then she
found like I'm not playing any other
games like I have you know a life and
this game is eating it up and I'm tired
like I can't keep doing this me I did
that through three seasons and on this
fourth season I don't think I could do
it I'm I'm level 40 on the season pass
now this is the first time I've been
this slow and I don't even know if I'm
gonna finish my season pass in time wow
this is
a game where I purchased
everything I mean every special edition
I got the messenger bag in my closet
like I love yeah I just saw that too I
was actually looking through a closet
cleaning stuff up I'm like oh yeah
there's that uh Hawthorne bag sitting up
there yes I
know it fits just right like I I love
that bag but
you know I'm I'm wearing my uh Jade
Rabbit hat right now oh yeah yeah
all my all my shirts all my t-shirts are
Destiny t-shirts I love well okay I have
a bunch of games
it yeah I mean hey it's Mario Day
[Laughter]
I was literally Sunshine back I was
literally deciding and I was like I had
the Gambit shirt and I was like for one
that always goes in the green screen too
Mario 3D All-Stars I was like
yeah absolutely today is the day of
Mario like respect to Bungie but it's
Sunshine Day I mean come on what are we
I know other people like oh my God
that's the worst Mario but no no for me
laughs
it's the one I've played the most it's
the one I like the most because it's I
don't know whatever see that's the one I
actually never played as much I I think
I played a little bit of it I won her
I'm 100 AD Mario 64. and I've missed
Galaxy
yeah so like but I played a little bit
of sunshine so I'll actually be curious
ever I want Galaxy 2 though that's the
one that is like oddly missing from this
so yeah I was wondering what two is that
on there right it's kind of weird
yeah
anyway back to where you are I'm sorry
um so a lot of my friends you know the
the fomo started hitting them and they
started going I can't keep up like
the you know these are people who you
know and I've seen their patterns like I
I play a lot of uh
uh not only do I play a lot of these
games but I also have done you know work
on this kind of game and I couldn't tell
you I couldn't tell you what those games
were
but I could probably say that you know
it's like 300 million people to play
games I've worked on right
um it's some it's some really really
High number right
um
so
what I've seen is that a lot of people
leave and come back and that's okay like
a lot of the metrics people want they
want like consistent engagement but what
we see for most players like healthy
players and happy players and the Diablo
3 team mentioned this not the not the
guys who launched it but the guys who
released the the really good expansion
that everybody liked right and they said
you are going to be better off having
players leave and then come back happy
like excited for the next content drop
then you are players who are miserable
playing every day
that's what they told Bungie Bungie
doesn't appear to have listened and I
think I get why
but I I feel like a lot of what's
happening to Destiny a lot of what needs
to change in Destiny is is they're
creating burnout and you know I'm one of
the first people who use the term fomo I
think I'm the reason that fomo was as
common as it was on Reddit because I
used it once and then like two weeks
later everyone was using it but fomo is
you know
we want people to play our games right
that's why we make games we want people
to play them and we need to keep the
lights on so we need we need people to
be giving us money when you go free to
play there's some anxiety there right
but human motivation is weird there's
this book I'm reading right now it's
called drive it's about like human
motivation it's by a guy called Daniel
pink and he's like
you know we we learned about operant
condition we learned about you know hey
we can you know ring a bell and dogs
know
you know food's here right right and
we've we've learned a lot about
psychology and how to you know make
people do things but what we didn't
really realize is after long enough
periods of time if play is structured if
the reward system is structured the way
the church if you have entirely
extrinsic motivation which is you know
stuff coming from the outside like doing
your bounties so you get Bounty rewards
if you if you're just that
what happens is play becomes work and
when play becomes work people lose
motivation
right now destiny with the the daily
bounties with
um you know with I think daily bound is
your big one bounties are good I was you
know in that you know piece that I wrote
years ago about why they failed their
fan base I mentioned bounties because
bounties were important but then they
brought bounties back in the worst way
by bringing back you know daily bounties
and these you know seasonal challenges
and triumphs and these I want to feel
special stuff right every time they do
that they they create sort of a game
where people feel like forced to play
their game and it turns into a hostage
situation and so a lot of well and that
doesn't happen right like Fairways right
now it's funny the way it's it say it
but it's accurate in terms of like you
said the fomo and then you feel like
it's a job sometimes like you and you
get this stuff done but continue I want
you to expound on your point so I mean
for me right like what would make me
happy is I'd love to be able to like buy
a season pass and then just do it at any
time right remember the record books in
Destiny one
imagine imagine Bungie just releasing
one of those every quarter you pay like
10 bucks
and or you know 10 or 15 bucks right and
you just get this new content and you
can get it at any point like imagine me
coming here like now and going and
buying a season pass from like a year
ago you know like the forge right right
um season the forge and I buy that and I
play through it and I unlock some
cosmetics and stuff I do that that would
make me happy
um you know because then I could feel
like okay I can take a break because
right now I'm not in the mood for any
multiplayer games I played uh little
nightmares last night uh Jedi Fallen
order I'm playing some Persona 5 like
I'm not in the mood for a big Co-op game
but I could feel that itch in the back
of my skull like I can feel it I know I
want to come back and play some co-op
but I'm not there yet not there yet so
so is beyond light
a little bit of that itch is is stasis
is any of that enticing you a little bit
to say you know what okay
come November I might be right back in
I I don't know if it's it's ever going
to be the same you know
um for me if we go way back we're
talking like Game Informer Destiny
reveal oh yeah yeah let's go they were
talking about and they mentioned you
know Charlemagne's Vault they mentioned
getting Thorn is the raid weapon from
that raid that never ended up shipping
right
um and it sounded amazing
um but one thing I remember is this they
talked about weapons like they meant
something you know like when you get a
weapon that weapon that weapon has
something to it and there's a podcast
that they did that's no longer on their
website but somebody found it on the old
internet archive and sent it to me and
the people a bunch of you to talk about
like yeah we want and I remember reading
this in an article somewhere but it was
like we want the guns you get to like
have a story like we want you to be like
okay I got this devil you know and this
is
yeah right like I'll have this for the
rest well it wasn't definitely yeah
Devils what was it better Devils better
Devils yeah
no better Devils is Destiny 2 gun this
is Destiny one gun oh this is
the original Vanguard and can that was
the devil you know because then they
released the devil you don't right
you're right I remember absolutely right
I thought you were reiterating Luke
Smith's Destiny 2 speed around launch
that's what I thought you were doing so
that's the thing that's the thing you're
right though like you're you're on the
right track so they talk a lot about
like the guns meaning something and you
know what throughout Destiny one's life
we could bring those guns with us like
we day one we start they they show up
they release uh dark below and people
like this sucks we want our guns and
they're like okay so how's the Wolves
comes along they give us the uh you know
the sort of Patchwork system you know as
a temporary here let's do this you know
let's bring guns forward a bit but then
they completely redesigned the gun
system
that means they can't really bring guns
forward but then eventually you know I
had this comedian I loved I've never got
that same role can't remember exactly
what it was but I I know I tried to get
it again I mean Community is like one of
the best shotguns ever in video games
and you know I when they brought it back
for like moments of trying if it's like
okay Bungie's finally getting this they
understand we get this weapon we fall in
love with this weapon and we want this
weapon until the end of days right and
then throughout all of Destiny 2 that's
what we had like that's what they gave
us they you know they brought in random
rolls put about 75 of those in with uh
forsaken which made me really happy and
then it's been about 25 every season
ever since
um you know and that's that's hard to
keep up especially if you're a game
designer and you're like I want every
gun to be different right you know
because like let's say we have 150 RPM
Scouts right that's my go-to example we
have three elements and we have kinetic
so we we have four elements right so we
can make four 150 RPM Scouts
and then we have to change them by going
like okay well we we have you know four
RPM Arch types so then you have 16 or
whatever right and so you can kind of
start increasing the number of guns you
get but that's if you're obsessed with
making them distinct me I I think guns
don't necessarily need to be distinct
right like if you give me a comedian
with the exact same stats as like
uh you know Matador 64 right I'm gonna
be happy because they they look
different and they feel different like I
mean just visually like in a sort of
audio visual sense like they feel
different even though they're they might
have identical stats they don't you know
obviously but like just for sake of
example right and so for me that's what
that's What mattered when I play Destiny
and I'm going through like trying to
grind out at one particular gun and roll
I'm expecting that time investment to be
respected
when I spend
um you know literally like a month
trying to get a gun or in the case of uh
in the case of my uh my God roll uh or
curated role I should say uh nation of
beasts I I sh uh I was sherpaing people
through raids and I started taking as
payment you have to let me do morgoth I
don't care what raid we're doing today
we're doing more gas that was the
favorite I saw maybe 25 of those guns
drop for other people before I got one I
I did maybe it took over a year to get
that gun
over a year from release and I finally
got my nation a beast and it made me so
happy and then a couple months later
they're like hey guess what
we're we're you know sunsetting your gun
oh and I'm like
I was like that yeah that one is that
one is it's uh but yes I get you is it
1360 right now this is the cap for that
one yeah
something like that yeah but like this
summer I worked really hard on the um
the Rasputin DLC right and I got this i
got this amazing it's not like special
it's not you know better than say
recluse or something but it it mattered
to me this uh fourth time's the charm
Firefly SMG from that rasputing DLC it's
just a nice little Arc SMG it feels
great to use it's got that silencer so
it sounds cool I got this purple skin on
it that makes it look great like
it's my gun I love it and it is expiring
at the end of the season and that you
know I spent money like real money
paying for that season pass right like I
bought that season pass
with this kind of talk be careful I'm
I'm just saying I'm over here
I have to say it I'm just listening to
the thoughts I gave Bungie money you
know and they they're now saying like oh
actually that thing you wanted we're not
doing that anymore and that thing that
you've you've known Destiny for the
whole time and you know Luke Smith said
in his piece like oh well you know
people uh you know people don't you know
um
wow I'm talking like that kid in that
one video that makes no sense
um you know he said something like uh
gosh I don't remember exactly how he put
it
it's a little brain did today sorry yeah
caffeine hasn't kicked in
so I'll tell you another Luke Smith
story that he said uh he used that
example of like there are some people
who got
Breakneck
should I go YouTube
just focus focus let's go bro stay on
track yeah you're good you go well
so he's like he's like hey look some
people are using Breakneck and they'll
never use anything else and that's bad
and I'm like why is that bad if you put
hung jury in Destiny 2 right that is the
only gun well I probably wouldn't
anymore because they made Scout ripples
bad but like yeah I love hungrius I
wrote like 5 000 words on it for my
personal blog like I love that gun I
wrote a thing you know referencing the
Tenacious D song I was like this is the
greatest and best gun in the world
um you know it I love Hungary sr4 it's
not better than other guns like there
are they're objectively higher DPS
weapons but for me that gun
was personal it's the game that I killed
oryx with you know it's the gun that I
killed uh you know um
the uh you know I've killed the war
priest with that gun so many times you
know and there are better guns I know
that you got that personal attachment
that investment right exactly it's the
gun that when I'm having a bad day and I
just need to decompress I take that gun
I go to the Dreadnought and I pop some
heads and it feels good because it's a
it's a firefly gun not a not a dragonfly
gun you know dragonfly sucks
it's not the jackpot not being useful
yeah yeah so for me like that gun
mattered and you know I I asked in my
article uh I wrote an article like the
season before uh and I have no idea if
they actually did this for me or not it
would be hilarious if they did but I
doubt it but I was like hey I wish you'd
bring back Hungary sr4 it's like a
little aside and my editor let me keep
that line in and the next season we got
oxygen sr3 and The Drifters The Drifters
gun and both of them have the same perks
you know they look like hung jury like
one literally looks like Hungary The
Drifters uh I think was you know the
watch
uh I don't remember no not not night
watch it's the uh the actual Scout that
he has he was selling it as the vendor
role and it had fi it had dragonfly and
uh triple tap
like that was his role that season okay
okay and it was like did they do this
for me this is weird rifles since Scout
rifles in Destiny 2 are no longer you
know good right like they have a great
season one amazing and then Bungie
posted that weird thing where they were
like people are trying to stay safe
yeah that's yeah you figured it out it
figured out that's a solar one right
yeah I just I just want to stop for one
second and you're making some valid
points and I'm sorry no no no it's cool
bro we getting the focus back on it's
like you're the guest you're the guests
but now all good but here's the thing
the question in the sake of Finn even
though I am emotionally connecting with
a lot of things you are saying and this
was part of my argument initially when
sun setting was announced in the sake of
fairness what do you say to those who
say okay we get it you love Breakneck
you love this gun these guns you have
these personal achievements and these
things these moments these memories
however when it comes to being able to
add new guns into the game you know we
feel as far as power creep and we can't
really make anything better like what do
you say when Bungie pushes back and he
pushes back you know on saying like hey
like we got to introduce new things you
know what I'm saying because at the end
of the day then you will just forever
use it what what what's your counter to
that all right all right so
try to keep me on on track here I'm
gonna try to make a couple guys
one and I'll explain this in a minute
but I'm not gonna explain it right now
because I'm gonna try to summarize them
one power creep isn't real
I mean controversy
number two number two
uh Luke Smith said you know there's
these people with Breakneck right but
you gotta remember when he was saying
these people will never leave Breakneck
he said and this is really interesting
to me he said uh like the example that
he used was Breakneck the gun that had a
perk at the time so broken that when you
activate the perk it reduces the gun's
damage
like the actual DPS drops right so his
example of this gun's so powerful no one
will ever stop using it was
because it sucks I like no people worked
hard for it and they loved it there's an
emotional attachment to that gun so
there's that
um there's also the fact that you know
like I said extrinsic rewards more
powerful than intrinsic extrinsic
rewards you know I have this gun because
I love it now I know we had I know we
had like YouTubers and streamers and
they're like oh my God but you know I
have to use this gun all the time and
it's like you don't have to you're
playing a game like a job and so you're
using the content to get you through the
quickest so you don't get bored so the
the YouTubers want the statistically
most powerful guns right of course
that's why they were all using you know
um yeah was it nameless midnight was
that the The Raid hand Cannon for a
while
I knew it had midnight in the name right
yeah they all use midnight coup for a
while and they all started using you
know Mountain Top when that was the
thing like the YouTubers all use the
meta right but we've had Teddy on Teddy
would say like people will use the most
effective you know what I'm saying as
far as whether it be DPS whatever to get
things done yeah continue yeah so
I'm gonna I'm gonna get back to this one
too but what if there was a solution to
that
so I've said no power creep yes I've
said what if there's a solution I've
said people need extrinsic rewards right
and then
um the last one for me is probably uh
you don't need to make your guns
distinct
and I know for Bungie that's like that's
like crazy right but like that's
sacrilege for them yeah for them it is
let me let me let me put tea this way I
want a new f-zero game right I know it
sounds weird we're talking about Destiny
in here I'm saying you know I want
Nintendo to make a new f-zero capture
shocking rules right s is your GX
incredible game
do you know why Nintendo won't make it
why
they said because we can't
something uh what I heard was like we we
haven't figured out a way to make this
game like a new game unique so I'm
sitting here not getting my Captain
Falcon because you know These Guys these
guys over at Nintendo
and like you know did did Flood really
make like Mario better did like the run
around the round planets really make you
know Galaxy a better Mario game like I
don't mind the gimmicks the gimmicks are
fine right but you know what breath of
the wild isn't really a gimmicky game
compared to other zeldas but you know
Skyward Sword was with Skyward Sword
really a better game than breath of the
wild I don't think so like breath of
wild is vanilla in comparison it's kind
of boring in that sense but it's a
better game it's more fun to play in my
opinion Okay so
I don't think you need to be unique
necessary you need to have personality
so when I get a Rasputin gun that just
looks cool and sounds cool I'm happy I
don't mind if the perks are the exact
same as a different gun
that's that's a
get me get out of me but I was like
you're literally saying you like your
new Rasputin gun that's them making a
distinct weapon you're like oh this
one's cool this one's fitting with the
season it's not a sink though is it is
it distinct like
the the model is the sounds are I get
that okay that's what I like okay
literally like so see what I'm saying
are you saying
yeah are you saying function versus
fashion almost
yes I am okay literally like perks is
one literally talk about fashion yeah I
was like but like if you go RPMs like
fire rates stuff like that's one thing
you've got the Aesthetics like the
sounds the looks and those are pieces as
well so you're okay if they make new
skins new sounds things the way they
like the reload animation all that stuff
but like the perks you know just keep
slapping the same ones on and you're
good
I I would I would like to see them
adding more perks you know overall
um like clown cartridge came back made
my day I have yes I I had a friend um he
just started playing Destiny you know
this is after I started slowing off on
it and he got that uh he got that that
um
the grenade launcher from I know what
she's talking about yeah monarchy right
yeah grenade launcher and he got it with
like full court clown cartridge you know
Masterwork I was mad I have I have all
but one perk on mine that's perfect like
he he had everything and it was like oh
man his clown creatures is great like
I'm glad they brought it back so I love
that they're adding new perks into the
fool and I don't mind if they you know
add those to guns but like
honestly for me I would be if you if you
like hey here's two completely different
guns visually an audio like an audio way
like oh this one has a silencer on it
you know that's not gameplay thing in
Destiny like silencers don't really
matter but like
I love the Rasputin SMG and if they gave
me another SMG this season I would track
it down right I would want it for my
collection right but I don't necessarily
need that gun to have like a totally
unique perk pool or totally unique
element or whatever because all elements
are basically the same in Destiny right
like it doesn't they don't do anything
different it's not like hitting somebody
with art will cause it to bolt you know
like lightning a bunch of people it's
not like Borderlands where the acid one
reduces armor like they don't they don't
got anything like that and that's you
know the elements are just match colors
that's fine so for me for me it's like
you know I want a good roll but I don't
mind if the gun if the gun is just the
exact same possible rolls but looks
different because I can still get a
different role on it right like I might
have one that's like okay I want this
one for crowd clear so I want fourth
Chimes to charm and dragonfly so I can
just go around spraying Non-Stop and
then this one though I'm gonna get a
completely different thing it's going to
be about you know busting Shields so I
can still build the guns differently
but their base stats could be the same
and I wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily
mind so that's that's interesting that's
my last point right so let's work our
let's work our way back see if I can
actually remember my points um
let's see uh so I said Power creep isn't
real and I know that's controversial I I
get it right but here's the thing I was
like I'm waiting on this one yeah wait
yeah so Bungie said in their piece the
reason that people get new guns is
because the new guns are more powerful
than old guns and I would disagree with
that I think if you take if you take the
hand Cannon uh kindled Orchid right
right which I'll go take Kindle dork oh
I had a god roll in that oh
clip of Rampage man it is it is special
right special
and you take that gun and you go into I
forget what's RPM archetype is but if
you take that into a raid right now
Garden of Salvation right you go shoot
somebody with that
what's gonna happen how many how many
headshots will it take to kill or like
you know weak point shots will take to
kill a vax at Max light
it'll take one or two usually right just
a regular like red bar Vex you shoot him
in the weak point he dies in one hit if
you get a brand new like this season
hand Cannon same archetype
brand like the the latest gun of the
same archetype and you take that in to
the same content at the same light level
one bullet still kills the guy
power creep doesn't really exist like it
does exist don't get me wrong it exists
as a concept like if everyone is using a
gun that takes one second to kill an
enemy
and you know then they release a new gun
that's 0.8 seconds killing me yeah
there's power creep but when everyone is
using uh you know the same gun in in PvP
um and they just make some other guns
just as powerful right more people use
more guns but the actual time to kill
doesn't change
that doesn't sound like power creep the
part you said is like hey we've got a
one second time to kill on this Auto
rifle cool well okay we gotta make
something more powerful now it's 0.8
seconds okay now we make something with
0.6 seconds that's power group and
that's what they're trying to not get to
so that's why I haven't
yeah what I'm saying is it doesn't it
doesn't actually exist in this game like
it can don't get me wrong there are some
guns that do have better ttks but we
don't see that every season when they
release 20 guns every season those guns
aren't usually meaningfully different
especially in like a raid like you go
take like I said either hand cannon into
a raid the new hand can isn't more
powerful people aren't going oh I want
this brand new seasonal hand Cannon
because it's going to make me better at
raids because that's just light level
you're just all they're really doing is
releasing a higher light level which is
permission into content and then yeah
that's a whole day I think you're up
that's a different argument though yeah
I agree yeah well that's and that's my
point like power level is what's
actually growing in the game actual like
affection uh Effectiveness isn't
changing all that much and hasn't for
years well and I think the actual
efficacy of of the weapons we're getting
is not changing at all
you know yeah I was like that's a piece
but it's like I think when
and I think that's an issue Bungie has
had with Destiny for a long time is
trying to
they're afraid of things being too fast
recluse is their prime example of just
breaking the game uh Master of Arms just
like mowing through people to a level
they're like well we can't make
something better than recluse be in PvP
because an SMG or even an auto rifle or
anything at this even medium range is
gonna just start mowing things over and
over and over and over and if they're
like well if we have to now top this
it's going to get down to a point where
you have like half a second time to kill
and it gets ridiculous so it's like so I
I think their worry is they did the
recluse the Mountaintop the
the Breakneck and they had a pinnacle
test yeah they had the Pinnacles then
they're like oh now we're going to do
Pursuits or what's next what's the one
in between ritual yeah and they're just
like pulling back and back and back and
they're getting to where you're saying
is like nothing is special which is also
a problem because now you're just like
hey let me get season 15's hand Cannon
out here in one shot this can okay
season 18's hand Cannon just pull it out
it's like you're just pulling the new
weapon out of the season but the hand
Cannon still shoots like a hand Cannon
so yeah I think so what about a solution
for you oh
what about a solution not only for your
problem but the YouTuber problem of I
gotta keep using the same gun okay
because that I think I gotta I think I
got a solution it's a two-part solution
okay the first part is
what if we used Pinnacle weapons as a
way of testing new perks
like what if you know what if we're like
Okay so this gun for this season is the
only gun with mastered arms and they
look at the numbers and go oh my God
mastered arms is too powerful so then
they're like okay next season rolls
around
here are a bunch of new guns and now
they can drop with mastered arms because
we've tested it right and now we know
it's too powerful so we're changing the
way master of arm works but like 20 new
guns get this perk suddenly people like
oh okay okay it was too powerful but you
know now it's a thing or you look at
Mega neuron we go okay kind of doing it
except
I would say that the you know they kind
of shy away from the Pinnacle perks that
they've introduced but I feel when
they've I would say they've kind of did
it but they haven't ever truly embraced
it but Katie I'll let you fit it I got
some some other thoughts on this what
you're about to say yeah so I think you
can I think you can go hey we'll make
these guns
a little overpowered for the season just
to test them but it also gives them
their time in the sun it lets them shine
it makes them feel special but then
everything gets moved in the pool and it
starts becoming part of the normal
balance pass I think if you do that
that makes everybody happier not
necessarily a perfect solution but
that's one way and the second thing you
do is you give every single weapon
mastery
warframe's got a system it's called
Mastery what you're doing is every
single weapon has XP okay you can take
every single weapon to level 30. when
you do that that hits your account so
like if I if I have I don't even know
how many I'm Mastery level 25 that means
I've done hundreds of warframes Warframe
guns pets I've leveled them up to max
level when I do that I get account Buffs
so I can carry more stuff than a guy who
starts day one like I can get more um of
these things that open special chests
I've got better inventory like I've got
all these cool stuff so imagine imagine
like being like all right I've got you
know a thousand ten thousand kills on my
you know recluse right yeah
what's that what's that policy that you
the dot dad bod pulse used to use
you're literally talking about ease go
figure continue yeah I had 40 000 kills
yes mastery
that exactly right imagine every single
gun in the game everyone has you know
get like one thousand ten thousand a
hundred thousand kills some I'm these
are hypothetical numbers right something
that you feel you could get through but
it's like imagine at X number of kills
or you know of course rocket launchers
aren't going to kill as much as a
primary because you know fewer ammo
right but you know some sort of or or
unlock requirements or something I know
Call of Duty has those on on some of the
the guns I think Battlefield has them
you know and you go through this and
then it gives you unlocks like say a
skin you know I paid money for skins on
guns that are expiring now okay I'm I'm
seeing the vision on this part I'm
seeing imagine on this part go ahead
imagine say uh one percent extra bright
dust on all your bright dust bounties
okay now that sounds bad for like one
gun right but imagine if say
20 of Destiny's 500 guns have that and
it's 20 extra bright dust you're
suddenly getting on bright dust turn-ins
right and there are you could keep doing
things like this you could you know say
add inventory space Oh when you max
these guns out you get five extra
inventory slots and that doesn't sound
like a lot but remember it adds up once
you do that then people are going okay I
have to bring in
all of my guns even if they're not
optimal but suddenly there's a thing to
Chase and it's an extrinsic reward or
yeah it's an extremities award not an
intrinsic reward but it gives you a
variety it helps push variety without
forcing you to avoid the things you love
right so like you and that's how I found
guns I loved in other games right like I
would I'd be like oh well this one I
gotta grind up and I start grinding it
and be like oh my God I actually really
like this gun so that's that's how I
would solve it is is giving every gun
Mastery and uh bringing in like new
perks like testing new perks with
Pinnacles so they all have their time to
shine but then we add it to the pool so
then we get more overall variety that's
how I would solve a lot of Destiny's you
know supposed problems yeah it's like
part of that's Destiny one of leveling
up your weapons so I mean you go back to
Destiny 1 when you have the little
circles you fill them in and then you
unlock those perks and that's one thing
some people love and hating that's kind
of divisive thing on some I really like
the idea of Mastery like Global account
objective to say I got yes 10 000 kills
with Scout rifles you know I get I get
to hold more Scout rifle ammo or I got
20 000 kills subscribe Scout rifles I
have slightly higher aim assist and
reload speed or something on those like
just for classes of weapons like I spent
a lot of time with pulse rifles
obviously 44 000 kills later
um
that's one of those it's like should I
have some benefits on Scout now they're
always worried about breaking the game
do you are they gonna let me have range
probably not uh are they gonna let me
have aim assist probably not but ammo
reserves for like a PVE situation uh
just something as you feel and as you
said like maybe I don't play SMGs that
often but if SMGs I can play those and
maybe it's like hey you get like two
more bullets in the clip I don't know
like there's nothing but they're so
worried about doing things like again as
I say it's like they're not going to
even range on this like pulse rifle
because they're like our sandbox is
pretty it's not no sandbox is ever
perfect but it's just like
those long-term incentives
right now would be perfect
right yeah so I would and that's that's
why you mentioned or that's why I
mentioned every incentive uh being an
account incentive and not a weapon
incentive because like I love getting
more better at killing [__] right but
they would yeah like the point you bring
up is great right that would break their
sandbox in a way they wouldn't like or
people would be like well the only
reason I got beaten at firefight is
because he had you know slightly better
or slightly better range right you don't
want that but I mean if somebody goes
well you know hey I got five more
inventory slots who's gonna get mad
about that nobody's gonna get mad about
that everybody wants you know five more
inventory slots like
yeah so that's that's why I think that's
what I would personally try to affect
but you know that's me no I get you I
think to double down on what you said
um I love your idea of Mastery I think
it's cool I actually at the chat someone
mentioned it as far as like um Call of
Duty used to do stuff like that and like
almost at XP grind and then it's more of
an attachment to the weapon and also I
was leaking in conjunction besides just
like ornaments right yeah how cool when
you have that unique ornament it's like
yo that's your you know vigilance Wing
or that's whatever your legendary that
you're using it and you've had that
amount of kills then yeah like this is
really cool I love the idea of Mastery
the problem with their thinking I'm not
that I agree with them I'm just how they
probably gonna push back is because they
still want
you know
the sun setting the sun setting thing is
just they they they want to remove
you know these guns they they want to
the pro the problem they have is this
they talk about the power creep
but with the issue I have with them is
then you can't say that and then reissue
Night Watch no yeah
that's what I'm saying I have kept
myself
or the reason I have four night watches
two from now and two from old they're
identical and every time I looked at
that I'm a Ryan reminder I'm like you
better not do this crap later on and
that's but I mean that's what I mean
power creep when I say power creep isn't
real I mean literally it is just the
number and the reason they're they're
doing it like they'll tell us
like power creep in and of itself like
when you described it earlier I would
say that's real like the way they have
implemented like our feeling of powerful
like our Guardians don't ever feel
powerful I can go into a basic strike
still die even though it's recommended
power 750. I have a level 1060 and
that's the difference of like your us
never feeling powerful in itself but
Power creep as they describe it on
weapons can get to a real thing but I
totally agree that we as Guardians I can
go around on patrol I should stomp
everything by nearly sneezing on it like
maybe maybe I should have maybe I should
have said that it was like different it
does exist yeah yeah yeah when they say
that power creep is the problem when
they justify it I don't think that's why
we're getting new weapons and and you
know talking to your uh example right of
Night Watch perfect example right right
that's it's clearly not true right is
there their reasoning is this we're
going to release new content every
season
and we need people to want to get the
new guns right and if you look at their
patch notes I'm talking from the
beginning of Destiny like remember when
they took out trip mines like Hunters
were like we only use strip mines
because all the other grenades suck but
she was like they only use trip mines so
trip mines must be strong every patch
note you ever see when Bungie nerfed
something it was you use this a lot and
so it must be too powerful it must be
too good they never actually looked into
why like uh sniper rifles you know hey
uh they use the exact same reasoning for
nerfing sniper rifles from the 20 buff
like they no one's using sniper rifles
let's give them a 20 buff a season later
let's take that away it's like well
that's gonna go right back to nobody's
using it right but they use that exact
same like people are just using it to
stay at a safe distance which no one was
but they always met they use it oh did I
disappear no no just cut out for a
second this is why we have the audacity
recording it's gonna sound better later
exactly okay cool I'm I'm sorry I I hope
it isn't my mic being no no no no
Discord okay well
they they use the exact same reason on
why they wanted to make Scout rifles bad
which is uh players are using them a lot
so it must be that players are trying to
stay safe every time it was like we
assumed the only reason people want
things is they're strong but when we
look at why people want things they want
Breakneck even if it sucks even if the
perk makes it worse because they like
Breakneck so Bungie's entire thing their
entire motivation every patch note I've
ever seen from them for nerfing stuff is
the only reason people use stuff is it's
strong and that's not why people use it
people use stuff because they like it
it's the fashion thing that we talked
about earlier right but it is
3x like believe me that still melts it's
not it's not a bad weapon it was good at
the time I I half agree with you on that
one it it was great and then they they
brought it down for a bit but now that
they brought assault rifles back up it's
a little better like you know it's it's
part of the balancing game and I get not
wanting to balance every single gun all
the time but if they if they stop
worrying about making all the guns
unique and they stop thinking the only
reason people want guns is cause they're
uh you know because of strength if they
think people want guns because they want
the gun that works for them the gun that
makes them the happiest you know some
people still play Pikachu and Pokemon
right he ain't the strongest you know I
don't I don't keep playing Charizard
because he's better than Rayquaza I play
Charizard because I like him you know
because he looks cool but Destiny
Pokemon in the same game they really are
like Destiny guns are Pokemon they're
not Diablo loot you know in Diablo it's
like this sword just looks kind of
different but it has it's the same point
now now you know you get back with me
now okay I wish you would Pokeball on
one I like this okay guns have character
their their personalities that fit in
our screen right they matter to us we
have our favorites regardless of power
they're like you know Diablo Diablo
weapons aren't aren't really characters
they're like really tiny pixels on the
screen that you know I get this ax oh
it's cool then I get an ax with better
stats all right that's cool we have that
in Diablo but Destiny isn't Diablo
Destiny's never been Diablo because
Bungie makes Shooters and the stats have
to say say the same so you know because
that's how that makes it good combat
feel like if you want a game where
weapons are disposable you can play the
division guess what nobody plays a
division as much as destiny
they loved us they love Division and I'm
coming back I'm I'm coming back to the
mega dungeon I'm so excited for the the
hundredth floor Mega dungeon that's
coming right but I'll be real with you I
don't have a single gun that I love in
the division like I don't have a gun
that's I'm keeping this forever
this is the point of that that's where
people were fighting me I hate to catch
you with the sunset that's what I was
saying I was like you can't use these
Apple to Apple comparisons because like
you said it was like these guns are like
Pokemon these These are these rare
attachments where you play these other
games those type of weapons and armor
don't have that type of Association it's
it's more of a generic thing that yeah
you may have stats and numbers in
division you
you know those other Exotics in division
but they don't have that same feeling
right and yep the proof is in the
pudding how is it and even he could
agree with me on this part you know what
I'm saying when we comparing that game
to this is that how is it they'll have a
raid or they'll have these things but
the player base doesn't stay at some
point
the player base leaves and then it
doesn't recover and then Destiny is
still here there's something
intrinsically still appealing that makes
Destiny addictive and people can say yes
to Gunplay people can say you know the
fact that you're Space Magic and
monsters and you're as opposed to
shooting a dude with a hoodie 55 times
you know that you can make that argument
right obviously right but the reality is
these guns I'm using your thing the
Pokemon they're red they're they're in
trained they're so unique the way they
design the things they do the sound you
know what I'm saying and then you put
this work you have moments Associated to
when you got this right that's what
makes you know for Neo Metro he's a
destiny division fan he's like I'm
taking my ball and I'm going home but
that's why you know what I'm saying and
that's why I tell people you can't use
that one-to-one uh comparison to other
looter Shooters and say you know they
just have to adopt what these other
Shooters are doing because that's the
uniqueness
yep and I'm I'm 100 with you I will say
division has pretty much perfect combat
like as a as a third person shooter it
is one of the best it feels intense the
levels are really well done like I love
that game and that's when I come back
for that dungeon yeah but
I'm not going to come back for that
dungeon the way that I did you know a
Year's worth of More Death encounters
right morgoth never got old to me I love
that encounter I mean I probably never
do it again because I finally got my
nation of beasts but I've done hundreds
of more guts it feels like thousands
millions who knows you know because I
wanted nation of Beats and now I got
Nation to beast and that's my gun and
then they're like we're putting an
expiration date on it's like why did I
do this why why do I play this game why
do I give it my time if it's gonna if
it's gonna say oh and now there's an
expiration date like it's I'm not gonna
say like they came out and promised this
to us they never said well actually they
did they actually did they said uh when
dark below came out I have this note
somewhere I I take I I wish that I had
to screen about five and a half years so
you know things can change yeah things
things can change but then I said they
basically said we hear you and we
understand that you don't want to lose
your weapons like these weapons mean
something to you like I I have the I
have the logs or not the logs but the uh
I took a screenshot but it's on the
computer in the other room so I'm not
gonna go get it but that's cool you know
it's like we yeah I gotta replace the
battery it sucks right now but it's like
we you know
we want to make sure that these these
guns stick with you and the initial
promise of Destiny like all that that's
why I come to this series and so if that
changes right if that changes why do I
keep coming back like if I'm you know if
I love I don't know if if I love you
know say Forza Horizon right
racing game that's all about festivals
and having a good time and then they
turn it into like a top-down you know
like top down like isometric Racing type
game and it's you know hey play from
this angle like it changes genre it
turns into turn-based racing game
somehow it's extreme but I understand
you in general yeah yeah I mean to make
an exhibit you gotta be stream right but
if it's particularly the thing that I
love about doing it which is you know
zooming over these Hills and gliding
through the air as the music hits just
right if they take that away then why do
I keep buying games in the series right
right you know if Dragon Age suddenly
doesn't have you know Dragons RPG stuff
I remember uh I remember hearing that
they were they weren't sure they could
actually get dragons in the first game
because there were issues making them
but they they got them in I don't know
if that's true but like you know I don't
know if they had mini in Dragon Age 2
but that was a bad game um but you know
I didn't like Dragon Age 2. like I
played the first game and I was like
this is what I love about the game is
all these things and then they took it
out Dragon Age Two I don't like that
game I've only played it once and I've
played the first game until Destiny came
along Dragon Age Origins was my most
played video game of all time oh no yeah
and this this is definitely you know
this is the risk they run with a certain
a subset of the base risk run I like
that right those are bars those balls so
it's like you know when they do that
it's just like okay they have to
understand this is not going to hit well
with everyone right and that some people
are gonna say nah I'm out you know I'm
not I'm not doing that you're not going
to take that away from me or whatever
whatever I think for me look I can sit
here and tell me on the face and say yo
if they do this they do that you know I
I've been through all this they gonna
call my bluff like I still love the I
I'm trying to think of a scenario
that they could do that I'm just like
okay y'all wilding out I'm not no you
know what I'm saying I've had moments I
think the beginning of dumb division
Destiny 2 at the vanilla stage right
when it first came very casualized that
was my foot down I'm like nope
I'm not doing this y'all giving y'all
having Hawthorne giveaway raid guns yeah
you know Trials of Osiris of mass the
double primaries you know I was not in
and they weren't even sixes at that time
yeah you had ability everything
everything was go slow yeah and Exotics
were oh we're gonna make ten percent of
your recharge rate of the abilities
probably how they should have been you
know that's an exotic armor you rock
that and you get 10 more recharge rate
and nah fam you you're not we're not
doing that so that's what I put my foot
down I said Okay cool so my point is to
say this and I'm just gonna this I have
to ask you this question because it's
another debate you touch the sunset
thing the other thing was not really
it's just a fun thing like
um we put a poll up which was like okay
D1 versus D2 now surprisingly this thing
the amount of votes this thing got was
insane I got everybody in the community
in it was it was edit finish tight it
was D2 winning I believe it was fit fix
your face if it fix your face I see you
smirk and stop it I'm literally looking
at my phone sorry
you're just trying to make a [__] happen
that's yeah how big do you have for you
don't make it happen so 52 to like I
don't know 48 whatever right so my
question to you where do you stand with
that like was D2 the better overall game
because the argument people say like
well D2 were fine things you know what
I'm saying and the quality of life
everything's better and there's still
better moments overall and then the D1
the hardcore was I know you know I felt
this was way better more hardcore like
where do you stand right now because now
it's the reason why I put the question
up we are now in the equal amount of
years of existence of both now D2 now
has that amount in so we're both three
year mark So now a total six total right
so where do you stand with that so if we
if we kind of list things out right
Destiny one has better level design it's
got better encounter design it's got
better Sky boxes like I could just go to
cosmodrome and just look at the sky
um you know
I'm about to get into shot the non-hises
I'm about to get two D2 but up I was
like
the sky boxes aren't skyboxes aren't a
reason right to love a game they're
great but okay so Destiny won you know
it also has hung jury it's got Firefly
that rocks it's got you know I can go I
can go into the Dreadnought and I can
take a yellow bar wizard down in like
four shots
okay in Destiny 2 if I take a Scout
rifle to take a yellow bar wizard like I
will run out of ammo before I kill it
you know
that to me it's a bit of a problem right
so so Destiny one I feel has like a
better weapon sandbox it drops it drops
legendaries at a rate that makes me
happier uh you know it it has
environments that I like more I think
Venus is my number one favorite planet
in all of Bungie history it's my
favorite location ever
um well I say that but I think Savo
Highway and Halo 3 might be the best one
they ever did Focus keep it D2 keep it
dusty but on but on Destiny on Destiny I
think Venus is their best planet right
vaults of glass in my opinion still the
best rate
um we're here like I love scourge of the
past scourge's past is basically perfect
well it's a glass yeah I love Scourge
um every time you go on that never heard
a Scourge guy every time we go in that
raid I love to trick people into going
the wrong way with the the speeder Chase
okay let's be like you know anytime I'm
teaching somebody I'm like hey so we're
all gonna just race through the store
ready and then we kill them and they're
like oh my God I'm like so now you know
the lesson don't go that way
um and then we go on and everybody
everybody seems to have a good time like
nobody ever seems to get pissed but we
always run raids four two like four
experience players two inexperienced so
anytime we need to pick up the slack we
got enough gotcha so we can make it
through and and as a result we've had
fun teaching people but you know so
there's a lot to love about Destiny one
if you put Destiny 1 on PC I would be
playing it still even though there's no
new content for it right it also had you
know Sparrow races it had so there's so
much there's so much that it has that I
love got you not just the art design but
like it has better weapon sandbox in my
opinion just like Scout rifles
specifically look better
um you know obviously they changed like
if you said Destiny right now what has
like better PVP uh Destiny 2 just
because Destiny one uh ended with that
awful special weapon Nerf oh yeah
remember that ruined it that ruined it
but I think
Destiny was less afraid to
you know be fast and hard right like it
25 second grenade recharge if you Max
your stuff out that's way better than
what Destiny 2 has done for all right so
there's a lot a lot to know about
Destiny Destiny one but
Destiny 2 is on it's on PC it runs 60
frames a second it's got mantling so
when I jump you can come back
I can mantle stuff like it's gone I'm
just loving it I love points these are
hilarious they brought machine guns back
in the machine guns like they [__] but
they're taking away Hammerhead so I
don't give a [__] anymore oh you know
you know like my favorite machine gun in
all Destiny was the first year dead
orbit machine gun which hit like I don't
remember the name but it was deviant
gravity a I think
um but it hit about like Hammerhead it
was one of those slower firing like it
felt great right
um
but for me just
it I would say Destiny 2 feels better to
play in the moment right unless you're
using Scout rifles just run around
popping people in the heads watching
their souls yeah
yeah yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry but you
know you shoot you shoot like a fallen
in the head right and you can see his
soul get torn out of his body you don't
see that in Destiny one
okay
what is it sounded like you now edu tuna
right right well that's that's kind of
come back
I think
ultimately at the end of the day
which game has bones of EO
oh my God
[Laughter]
jump yep
and you know if I mean they're gonna
bring ball to Glass back in Destiny 2.
yeah we gotta talk about it but
they said something about maybe bringing
champions in if they put champions in
then Destiny one destiny one wins like
by what the [__] come on all right hold
on I gotta stop you I know we off track
it we gotta get into this 12. but sorry
I gotta stop you for a second listen so
Champions would disqualify fall if they
like if we come in with all dude think
about this we did have wells of Radiance
we didn't have any of this craziness and
now we bring in stasis into
you can't put this in this argument
faulted glass is it gonna have a chance
continue
[Music]
I feel that and I respect it but
but Champions here's the thing what I
love about Destiny's being able to bring
in what I want to bring in that makes me
happy right okay when I when I do like I
remember people being like you have to
have yellow horn I have yellow horn I
would go in there with sleeper and I
would mop up like I would kill everyone
a sleeper because sleeper is my baby oh
and I can out damage I can out damage
everyone on my team with a sleeper just
sit in the back of the room while
they're like oh dipping in and out of
the bubble shooting you'll be like I
beat you on damage yeah exactly EPS was
crazy it's also better in Destiny 1 the
destiny 2 like sleepers Federation they
disrespected yep I never got I never got
the uh
was never able to get the Catalyst which
yeah I'm still working on it could do
but you know for me it's like
I like bringing being able to bring in
what I like and so when when every
season they're like oh now you have to
level up and then you get you know this
mod so you have to use SMGs against you
know one of the reasons I'm using Ray
Clues still I mean I finally got the the
receiving gun but one of the reasons I
was still using recluse was I could put
mods on it that I needed to break down
barrier Champions I don't I don't like
burying Champions that much if they if
they had mods that were like utility
mods or if they had Champions that
weren't you can't you know hurt this guy
like they weren't annoying you know
probably have fun like oh you know what
if the guy who came in and like just
gave everybody a random over Shields
um they do technically I guess with the
uh the orb dudes yeah right oh the
server but like no oh believe me I could
go deep on the Champions being they're
not fun they're frustrating to play
against because
for one it's like you gotta run the
double Prime areas to fight both types
unless like because you don't have a
choice therefore it limits your loadouts
they still haven't fixed the exotic
thing except they finally had a seasonal
mod in there where you're like I can use
pulse rifles for a first but no like
champions for me have been
and again you watch people in like the
barrier it's like the way they fight
them in
um like Grand Master night falls you
watch people playing those things I get
that people have figured out how but
sitting back and going pew pew pew okay
make sure the Shield's down like move
the shield and it's like wait for it to
get back up keep the damage like the way
the the champions
function like you said it's like hey
have somebody come in and he has this
like overshield buff
and you got to take him out before
anybody else can die and it disrupts
combat it doesn't make it to where it's
just like kind of to the point of
it takes the sucks the fun out of it I
can understand the disruption of like
hey a champion walks on the scene oh
crap he's the big Focus we got to take
him out right well I can't even touch
him right now what that like that's yeah
that always kind of sucks the wind out
of it so there was there was a point
where me and my my squad when we go into
the side to your nightfalls it was like
yeah you have Divinity and you guys have
uh the the one gun that you know just
[__] him up completely not right yeah
yeah yeah that and I love Izanagi like I
was one of the early adopters I love
that gun I'm sad they nerfed it because
the gun feel is the best any sniper's
ever been in my opinion owned Edge it's
my second favorite sniper rifle in all
Destiny history right there's only one
sniper rifle that's better and it's not
in Destiny time I already know what it
is it's my first exotic ever you know I
got icebreakers
use a Sandbox breaking guy look at you
yeah I mean I don't think us Ricker's
actually that bad you have to wait like
what eight seconds a shot for every
single shot like I never thought it was
that bad it just I love the way it
looked I love the way it feels cool and
I love the fact that it had Firefly on
it
um very cool you know it was it was a
salt like it felt good yeah and I don't
really think the like considering how
often green ammo dropped especially
before the special weapon Nerf I thought
it was a great gun but you know that's
me that's me I just I love the and it's
also my first exotic so I have to love
it right we got that Affinity with not
not to cut you down we gotta get because
I even realize
we gotta get the 12 popping but uh I'm
glad I'm glad you made that point
because um you know at the end of the
day these were the things that you've
missed out on and I just wanted to I I
I'm glad you gave me your feedback in
reference to D2 versus D1 and obviously
the sun setting thing you know
tremendous tremendous points of
contention and many a battle was fought
on the battlefield here well I mean we
gotta keep things interesting right
right of course if we all agree to be
boring exactly you know what I'm saying
so that's what we do but I gotta give it
back to e what's going on this week
oh besides the uh PS5 launched
pre-orders dropped uh RTX 3080 sold out
in seconds
um Bots are probably going to destroy
the pre-orders for Xbox next week
everybody knows when that one's coming
so it's an organized launch but I'll be
like
it is crazy in the world gaming right
now and then Bungie's like oh by the way
we still have ghosts we gotta mess with
so
um
well obviously we got The Travelers
chosen been messing around with that
it's kind of fun
um it's got potential I've seen some
really cool people do some cool builds
with that one but we finally get some
love to ghosts how how long overdue has
this been like they're just this like
thing taking up space kind of crappy
perks if you don't have Guiding Light on
yours you're basically just doing it
wrong I mean that's basically what
they're for hey bonus to XP cool like
yeah they don't really I don't really
care too much about anything else like
the the what is it the chest perk is
nice what about instant summon well
that's the other one those are the three
you need you need instance Summit and
Guiding Light and then if you have the
planetary chest planetary one yeah if
you have that for where you're going I
have I have the moon ghost the the lunar
ghost or whatever lunar shell that
literally has those two and then if you
just pull it from collections I have one
for every planet so that's literally the
ghost I've only used for a year so
haven't touched them
finally they're getting an update uh
they basically said ghosts have been
basically haven't received any
meaningful updates and they haven't
really had anything for us to do with
them so finally we get some stuff so in
Beyond Light Ghost have received a
system update which uh which shares some
functionality to to what was done with
armor in Shadow keep so ghost shells
will now have energy levels and access
to mods with various energy costs
instead of being pre-loaded with
specific perks
uh the treatment has been applied to all
ghosts outside of the generalist shell
which I don't remember what that one is
yeah it's the very first it's the
destiny one show okay it's just the base
I figured it was like some basic like
starter yeah just a orange and white guy
okay
regardless of the tier whether it be
exotic or legendary it doesn't matter uh
selection of mods will be available on
all ghosts by default while the
remaining ones will be obtained uh via
various gameplay sources key factor
right there we'll touch on for sure uh
information where they can be found will
be learned in collection so go to
collection soon as you log in we'll
figure out where those come from Ghost
mods will be obtained from gameplay
reward loops and will not be purchasable
from eververse big giant Round of
Applause there ghosts have now have four
mod slots uh three are unlike the by
default the fourth is unlocked by
masterworking now the four slots are an
experience mod slot tracking mod slot an
economic mod slot and then an activity
mod slot which is unlocked when you
Masterwork am I looking into it that
one's actually going to be kind of
Awesome
uh they go through a couple different
examples
uh they say a couple ghosts like The
Kill tracker Ghost and the Leviathan
boss kill perks will remain intrinsic so
there's a couple that may have one or
two locked but most of them you're gonna
be able to pick what you want they go
down into a couple of pictures which I
can't show but basically they show
you've got your experience ones and they
show like say for the experience track
okay you've got level one through six
and each one seems to match with its
energy cost and like say the one the the
blinding light which is the Experience
ghost mud it increases the XP gains by
12 so my guess is it's two percent per
level
um and then it also says this mod is
fragile and will expire at the end of
season 15. so I know there's a lot to
unpack there
um first big overall take from you guys
are you guys excited about Ghost mods
get our guest
well uh yesterday I was talking with
some of my old clanmates about this
um well none of us were playing Destiny
Ghost mods coming right back let's go
shots and they all said they all said if
basically if Destiny was in a in a place
where they were happy with it this would
be huge this would be the best thing
ever
except for that part about expiring mods
for the whole season so be because you
know we talked about like guns or
Pokemon right one thing that Bungie has
a problem with is
they uh how do I put this in a way that
makes sense
um not to y'all but to me how do I how
do I make myself
uh say this and not sound crazy
um Bungie's a problem with drops right
jump into a game we run through a strike
and we get blues and we're like what you
know the two tokens in a blueprint why
is that like like what's the fun of that
like why are we grinding this over and
over and I get that you need to play
content and it needs to be useless at
times like that's you can't always have
good stuff or it gets boring but like
because you need that anticipation right
you need that build up will this be good
right so you have to have bad loot in
there for it to be good but they just
need more stuff to drop they need more
like I'm gonna go here and I'm gonna do
this I mean I talked about this a while
ago like you need that directed Chase I
would love to have been able to like go
to Titan and any content whether it's
Gambit map whether it's just doing
patrols you always get stuff that's
associated specifically with Titan so it
sounds like bringing the bringing the
ghost mods in means maybe you know we'll
be able to like do a strike and in
strikes we get these mods do Crucible
and these Cruise you know these ones
they did mention activity kind of mods
yeah yeah
so that's that's that's encouraging like
the idea of being able to Target like
this evening this is what I want to play
I don't want to do everything I just for
a couple hours I'm gonna play this
tomorrow I'm gonna do that you know once
you start doing that that's I mean
that's where Destiny one really excelled
was every night was different and I
didn't feel like I had to go to every
planet and every vendor and you know 60
bounties right
if we can get that back in Destiny by
making the loot chase a little bit more
directed more specific I think that's
really exciting but that's me no I I
hate you I mean definitely some valid
points there I mean for me this was
a pleasant surprise you know I didn't
expect them to do anything with ghosts I
mean to be honest ghost wasn't even on
my mind let's just call it what like
that's the last thing I was thinking
about but yeah I mean to give them
utility you give them some specific
functionality I like that they're adding
the energy system to it I like that
there's going to be choice you know what
I mean um one thing that excites me is
the fact that you know I don't have to
carry like eight ghosts on me just to
switch which planet am I on Titan damn
let me get the cash resource you know
what I'm saying exactly so now and then
let's be real too like some of those
ghosts look aesthetically cool and they
got whack purple just like yeah I'm like
nope not gonna use that one not gonna
use it so it's just like you know that
that part is cool you know I like the
fact that I think they mentioned
um as far as the contender shell stuff
you know with the um unique the ones
that have those super unique stuff like
that supposed to do their stand correct
right so the Leviathan Ray you know what
I'm saying so that that's cool I mean
again pleasant surprise I do agree with
Doc I don't know how I feel about
aspiring mods on it like I don't know
where I'm at with that that's like
you're getting to my topic but we'll get
there yeah yeah I'll I'll let you get
I'll let you rock I mean overall
you know I I like the decision making I
think also to expound on Doc's Point
there's gonna there's days when I jump
in the desk I'm like look Iron Band is
here right let's use an example I'm
gonna run to Saladin I'm gonna grab all
his Pinnacles right then I'm gonna run
the Shacks I'm gonna grab all the Shacks
joints and let's say trials is dead I'll
say week two then I'm gonna grab all um
what you call safe one teams
I can now get that Ghost Shell in that
perk and say yo Crucible drops you know
what I'm saying I'm gonna get X Y and Z
and the thing that I really liked was
that one that said
better chance of enhancement prisms yep
better like think like I want to see a
golf ball one
yeah it looks like it's pushing us into
activities though like that that's a
good mod then because it means you can
log on for the evening and just go
farming prisms that's good that's what
we want we could do it in Gambit you
could do it in strikes
right and there are days in Destin we
all been all of us to hardcore in here
where you know you're going to set your
mind to just strikes today or just
Gambit today and now you can effectively
farm and get benefit I like that that's
big now I'm gonna let e go because I
know where he going but the other part I
was gonna say is overlay him had that
one so yeah go take it away no it's like
me first I like the choice so you're
like hey I'm working on leveling up got
my season pass up I'm going through cool
all right I'm decently through the
season I'm season rank 150. let me lower
my XP buff down let me crank up my
chance to get enhancement prisms it's
heavy weight it's void singe and the
Vanguard strike playlist I'm loving this
today my machine guns smashing
everything cool I'm gonna go bust up
strikes for a while and I get a chance
at these prisms in just the strike
playlist this match made it's not like
you know it's not killer nightfalls or
crazy in-game stuff and it's a chance to
get some currencies
this is like that was Pro that was the
second that was the biggest thing for me
on a positive was the fact that
something like enhancement prisms is
farmable in an activity that you don't
have to pull your teeth out on
so that was big
um and then somebody was saying like
that's worth six energy
and the one next to it for say Vanguard
looks like it's four energy having a
similar symbol somebody's like that
one's probably enhancement course yes
for the four there's nothing higher than
six for prisms so I don't think golf
balls are gonna be in here just thinking
it's um
you'll be able to buy them though that's
like like so if you get 10 you can go
buy and if you can just Farm them and
now the key is the drop rate if it's
like it's a chance and I'm like dude
I've done 20 strikes and I've got zero
yeah it can't totally suck because if
it's gonna cost me six energy on my
ghost shell and I'm giving up experience
on the other side to do this
it can't completely suck so that's I
will be curious to drop rate
um they have other things on there one
of them looks like the little
helmet which looking through this season
pass I would assume it's seasonal gear
drops the same way like hey when you
play crucial matches you get a higher
chance at seasonal gear drops
same way the season pass work it's the
same icon I want to actually go check
the season pass oh damn nice
so you've got that the little triangle
might be like a seasonal currency
possibly like you can get that more
frequently during whatever activities
now there's the one that's six and four
that's like probably enhancement prisms
enhancement cores there's another one
that's four with another like prickly
boundary around it I don't know what
that one is I could like figure out what
that one's gonna be specifically
um because we have Vanguard tokens we
have Crucible tokens we don't have
Gambit tokens per se maybe it's a way to
get like higher rank in those like if
you have like the seasonal vendor rank
or anything like that yeah because
there's a ghost that I have now it's
like a game I call it the game it goes
it gives you percentage of experience
specifically in that mode so it could be
just like hey this is like uh Vanguard
doesn't really have that as much but
Crucible specifically is the one I was
thinking of so maybe they're changing
like infamy more whales and extra
Infamous somewhere probably buried in
all of this
now the big giant asterisks and question
mark was and this is kind of how it made
me think of the entire entirety of year
four
the modest fragile will expire at the
end of season 15. I'm like okay so first
questions one it also shows that on
blinding light so what is the experience
like maybe what one through three or
four those might be like the part
because some mods are going to be
permanent period right there's gonna be
some that we earned so like you go into
some activity and say maybe you beat the
new dungeon and that's how you get the
five or the six right and they send you
and you have those for the whole year
I'm like okay but here's the issue with
mods that last for a year
mods that you like if you're gonna earn
mods in season 50 and that lasts for
like a whole three months that's a
problem so then they're gonna have to
front load most of it to be like hey
there's 20 mods in season 12. there's
like eight in season 13. there's like
three in season 14 maybe there's one in
season 15 for this last little hoorah
because then all the year four mods go
at the same time but is the way they
explained all that so I'm like
so you're gonna give me everything at
the start and then later on the mods
aren't gonna like or you're not getting
there's no incentive to do 20 new mods
in season 15 when they go in like
potentially two and a half months
especially if the seasons are a little
shorter so squeeze them all in every
season has to be about 10 weeks instead
of 12 weeks so they're all gonna have to
be shorter to fit them in so good
question do we do we need new mods every
single season
no because it seems like it would be
more because players a yearly basis like
an annual thing yeah yeah that's that's
what I think that's what would make me
happy I think about like a lot of other
service based games and they don't
Bungie tries to add something for
everything every single season and it's
like you know I wouldn't mind I wouldn't
mind waiting a little bit like you know
warframe's like hey here's the planet
here's a bunch of new systems do that
and then they they do a completely
different expansion for a completely
different game mode and we play that for
all and then like okay here's a new
planet you know and they so they Pace
things a bit Destiny I get the season
model but I wonder if it's a Death March
for the devs it seems like it's really
hard to to keep that it's like less I
mean this is a totally this is a whole
different channels because you talk
about season pass well it's like even I
mean we've said that too it's like maybe
it's like two more seasons instead of
three more seasons like some way to make
it to break it up where it's like you
know do you do like the six month like
injection of content so people don't
feel like they live in it where you dump
it all once you do a big mid-season
update and then you know you can do a
couple live events in there I don't know
how many stories they're trying to tell
is that why they're doing Seasons where
it's like little threes like a
consecutive like see this year's
narrative has been kind of cool
some have been very disjointed but
they're working on connecting them and
it seems to be getting better so it's
like is it the pacing of the story that
it needs to be three months is six
months too long
that's a whole different discussion
because believe me we've beaten that one
today yeah yeah no I'm I'm the the main
reason I'm asking was it's just like
I wonder if the the temporary mods do
exist to like you were saying be able to
basically just go hey we have some new
mods to add but we don't have to worry
about breaking ghosts because
you know that might just be a way for
them to test what mods could be
permanent later
I think a lot of it comes down to to
testing sandbox stuff and and then
seeing kind of like what breaks stuff
and also I think they could apply an
opposite approach which I'm not
necessarily necessarily going to agree
with but they could also do something
like introduce more powerful ones
towards the end so did it's like okay if
it really breaks it did they only get it
for two but you know say a month or
whatever it is two months and then it
goes back away but um yeah I mean this
is
that's the only question you know saying
how are they going to handle you know
this whole
expiration of the modding because again
it again we said with sunset sometimes
it does not feel good sometimes to
regrind things you've already had and
that's something they they're going to
have to contend with so they're gonna
have to be very creative in this regard
you know kind of thing but overall yes I
do like the fact that you know they're
applying the the Energy System there
that you know we can now have multiple
things within it you know what I'm
saying so I don't have to you know if I
got that ghost that got the speed demon
Sparrow you know spawn I could use that
with it in conjunction with XP thing or
an activity thing you know and and you
know whether it be cash resources or
treasure searching and stuff like that I
like hey being able to mix and match and
have the combination I want for my play
style for that day
yeah and the fact that you only probably
have to get one ghost like hey this one
looks cool just maybe the one I use for
the year one you need to level up one
ghost you can move it between your
characters and maybe you do three just
so you don't have to but
like this is not like hey a seasonal
armor kind like there's no power level
this is just gonna be with you there's
no infusion ending as long as this
system stays around for a while your
ghost is going to function mods are just
going to come and go and be earned so
like generally I'm excited about the
idea of for one ghosts not being mostly
useless
yeah oh I mean but also the customizer
hey I want more XP hey I want to farm
stuff pick you know pick you know do
your choose 10 system from Call of Duty
and be like yeah I'm going for my prisms
instead I want XP right now oh crap I'm
low on glimmer let's go Max glimmer let
me go just Farm some strikes glimmer it
up okay we're back I'm good yep so
totally depicted yeah I mean I'm most
excited about the prisms just I'm really
really oddly wondering about the season
15 for fragility of mods to be like how
are they gonna
release the mods that potentially all
work within a year if season 15 is like
we out of here in three months like
who's gonna grind for it if you know
it's gone that short yeah yeah because
weapons and armor they have that year
but they were like hey seasonal mods are
gonna be year-long right
I I have a question but I worry if I ask
it we'll get back into the debate about
expiration
why grind shards if you're gonna Master
work gear that's gonna expire it's gonna
explain it why are you gonna Max like
like I've maxed out my guns for kill
trackers and now you're telling me I'm I
can't keep that kill tracker in a year
like so why grind shards if you're
grinding for something that goes away
doesn't that make them ephemeral
like I I've I've like I like what you're
saying about like wanting to Grand
shards but I would it'd be amazing in an
economy where they they stay around but
since loot expires
and in conjunction to your argument
would be an e have also had an issue
with is the price for Energy Master
working specifically right so when you
match the work actually guns as well
like you Masterwork weapons and armor
this is a tremendous cost right the
enhancement prisms the legendary shards
the glimmer you know what I'm saying and
then that last step which is the golf
ball to get it to the you know to the
10. this is expensive so you know like
you said to tell it to tell a base after
you've mastered work this thing yeah now
that's not gonna get that's not gonna go
with you
that's a tough sell it you then like you
said the question and how do they make
that attractive to even do they can help
make the currency so hard to come by
that's my point well it's like because
that just pisses everybody off because
people are farming not to be like oh you
can't stock them up so people are
farming the crap it's like that's the
source of a different issue
you can't hold 10 then that's a
different problem but it's like if you
make them more readily available
I would toy around with armor more you
wouldn't have quite the worry of losing
it after a certain amount of time if
these types of things MMO light problems
it was like dizzy actually like nails
there I was like no but it's like they
they talk about the MMORPG but there's
so much still a shooter and not the MMO
yeah and that's kind of the point it's
like you talk about the guns that have
these attachments but you also have a
game where I can die everywhere no
matter what level I am
so it's like they can't have their cake
and eat it too but now at this point I'm
just looking at the cake and I can't
even eat it like I was like it's in the
wind that was good that was good like
like the problem of
if they you guys talk about like sun
setting of weapons stuff like that if
there was a like a new light level and
like new content came out that was
actually going to you know it's going to
require a higher light level but if most
of the game if there was like hey we
have a new planet
Europa to go walk around that planet you
gotta be a higher light level because
Patrol's even gonna kill you okay that
would be a way to start being like okay
like literally everything at this point
I gotta go get you know newer stuff
right and that's a point
they have a floor right like in Destiny
one uh
you they sort of enemies will scale up
sort of but at the same time like a
level 16 you couldn't go into the
Dreadnought and have an easy time win
that first released
like those guys hit really hard but once
you leveled up and hit Max then they hit
just as hard as the guys in level one
zone so it's a weird floor like their
bouncing is odd but they're doing it to
make the best feeling shooter which I
respect because that's way better than
going into Division and being like Oh my
God it's taking 20 minutes to kill this
one guy because I can't hit a shield
yeah I love the game I love the game
when the damage numbers feel good but
like right as a shooter as a shooter
like Destiny's good feel is because they
don't tune enemies like that so I'm like
torn I get your point and I I totally
it's weird like I have to agree and uh
it's what what game are we making here
are we making a game about bullet
sponges or are we making a game that
feels like a great shooter I'm always
gonna lean I think shooter side
personally and that's where it gets to
be a weird debate if they're like hey
we're gonna embrace the MMORPG and I'm
like you're still a heavy shooter with
loot
I mean that's what they are they are a
shooter that feels amazing that has loot
okay my issue with Avengers I haven't
done a review I know other people have
I've tried not to watch them at some
point I may put one together but it's
just you know I gotta crap or get off
the pot but the biggest thing with
Adventures it is worse in almost every
aspect because it is just numbers
the gear doesn't look different you're
still the same moves and abilities and
skill sets uh even the loot that you get
doesn't change how you look like you get
a Hulk
what is this so it's like yeah so I'm
like okay so I got a Hulk rib cage so
like a number went up a little bit but
it was like even in that though I'm
going around and I'm still getting
absolutely squished and I never play
powerful so it's like even in a game
like that where you're like okay now I'm
getting these num numerical things that
don't change the look I don't have a
physical attachment I still have the
exact same skills it is pure numbers to
a point of and but it's also oddly
balanced the way Destiny is because I
can still die for one really fast but no
matter what mission I launch it balances
to my level so I never can go into an
old thing and be like cool I can go
stomper that's the thing about like I
mean yes I reference the world a lot but
a MMO you're like this zone is level 15.
well I'm level 60. you can like walk
through there and look through stuff and
be like you're dead you're dead you're
dead you're dead without even like I
could go solo a dungeon when I'm level
16 at like a level 15 dungeon without
even batting at night no matter where
you go everything kills you in these
games and it's like
that's a weird thing like there should
be certain places where you get to feel
powerful and nothing but then as doc
said it's like it's a shooter it's like
if there are certain places like okay so
my hand Cannon's still one shots cool
but now it's like okay do you get to the
point where my SMG like shoots him in
the toe and I still kill him I was like
how do you make a shooter feel that way
so it's like I don't envy Bungie of
trying to make this happen but it does
feel weird at times and it's a weird
thing to balance I know so I just
knocked myself in a circle but it's just
it's odd
it's weird because I don't know how to
fix it uh well you brought up an
interesting point though
um when you mentioned that you know they
say they're trying to make an MMO right
and maybe the leveling thing isn't what
we need to focus on but it's actually
like loot like build variety right maybe
it's less about maybe it's less about
what we're doing with and ghosts kind of
help with build variety which is cool
but like I was talking with a friend who
makes
um roguelikes so really randomized games
right he's like yeah the problem that
Bungie has is their randomization only
has like one level of randomization and
you need like three before it really
starts to get really interesting I mean
you can play a game like Diablo and like
you're like oh yeah I had a friend he I
logged in and I was like what is this
and he had like 16 summons running
around behind him right right and it's
like yeah well I built this this and
this and then I got another friend who's
playing Division and he he got his perks
in just such a ways wearing all these
unique pieces of gear that he he can get
like 10 million damage headshots
um but he has to play in cover right and
that's what's cool
change the way he plays which means that
he can make different builds and that's
going to change the actual like you go
into the same mission right one time
you're in cover another time you're out
of cover like reach Dynamics like that
make the game feel more varied no so
there's one thing I wish they do yeah
that's what I love about them that that
build stuff and and being able you know
the mid Max and have specific legendary
armor like they have those sets oh
legendary Amber sets God we've talked
about that forever we talked about since
flash was here we was talking about that
yeah right so it's like last year so
it's like at the end of the day it's
like I they still
dip their toe but they don't they don't
really embrace the full things like
stasis even your fragments and aspects
but that is like a baby version of a
build it's not like right here's the
like perk tree of like you know three
ten people like you look at uh is it
outriders is that it would I always get
that name wrong the new one yeah I think
that's it yeah people can fly yeah
people could fly so like they have yeah
three different skill trees and you're
not gonna be able to get everything you
can go deep down one and really
specialize in a place like
that's what it's gonna take for them to
get to that to embrace the RPG is like a
skill tree that matters having builds
having that Synergy that works with like
your weapons like maybe you're it like I
know being a Healer would sound strange
in this game but you have a warlock that
has a rift
you have the horluck that has a well and
you have your healing grenades and then
you could go deeper into that heel store
like hey if you spec healing I get
double nades my riffs come up more often
but only the healing ones because those
are helpful right like there are ways to
go deeper and they have
they like as you said the toe is barely
in the water testing the temperature but
they are so far from like a deep skill
treat RPG like they got a long way to go
the builds would be huge I would love
that I want I want the damn sets I don't
want yeah I want to be able to get a
Titan and I want to be able to go in and
be like every guy I punch gives my
allies over Shields you know and if I
have a shotgun that you know increases
my punch damage suddenly I'm bringing
that in right like I want all these
things that turn me into like a close
range killing machine whereas like maybe
with my hunter I'm like I'm all about
Scout rifles and I'm all about you know
back to Scouts he's always back to
Scouts he's noticed that he's Scouts I'm
a Hunter we're like what else am I gonna
carry right you know I want to be like
one around and be like yeah pinging
these guys with head shots at range that
like say you know marks enemies near
them or poisons enemies you know I want
to be able to really do some weird stuff
in this game and they they need to just
embrace it but I imagine their systems
are really complex like yeah we've heard
reports their tools are a problem so I
think this is a it's one of the things
you have to design for early on and
Bungie everything we know about their
history is like
I think Jamie told me uh they made Halo
in eight months he's the guy who
designed the warthog oh wow you know
like they've been building it over years
but like as an RTS when they actually
sat down and made the game the game that
we got Halo Combat evolve was like eight
months you know Halo 4 they had all
these cool or Halo 2 they had all these
cool ideas threw them out rebuilt the
game really quickly yeah it's a thing
they do a lot Jason schreier's book they
did it with Destiny yeah plus one pixels
so I I feel like part of it might just
be not sitting down and going this is
the game we want to make and then making
that and that's a problem that we have
industry-wide it's why you know all
these studios are really big and they go
you know oh we gotta you know work on it
till it's done like blizzard did that
right and then they released Diablo 3
which didn't work out for them um you
know then they had to release an
expansion to fix it to fix it yeah you
know when you have a lot of money yeah
you can spend a lot of time on polish it
doesn't necessarily mean you should have
spent that much time making it you know
if you spend a lot more time in pre-pro
and you knew what you wanted you knew
how to build these things right from the
get-go you could build your Tech to do
it but they don't a lot of this is you
know bolting things on I heard Jade
Rabbit uh is hardwired basically so they
can't they can't change the perk even
though it's actually better to just do
headshots than use the exactly yeah
that gun gets to shine momentum control
was almost built for Jada yeah oh my God
momentum control was such a cool idea
like that's I was literally playing that
yesterday because I was working on it
was like the tribute Hall I need to
random attributes for my bad juju
Catalyst I'm like do away I'm like okay
put on the old callous armor and go into
these activities cool and then momentum
with Joseph we get more kills in there
and I was going through I was like
I like that now that game mode can be
frustrating for some people I get it the
kills could be quick I could body shot
somebody with a sniper that goes both
ways
the fact that you get to have a game
mode where the sandbox feels different I
love it not for that part and that's why
I know why you like Mayhem like you like
I like this not like ever it's just not
like here is like here's your basic
sandbox with a code of like Clash
control and it's like you're just
putting a coat of paint on the same feel
it's nice to have those times where
things do feel different not all the
time I mean some things need to be
standardized I'll fit it but I do like
when you know you go into momentum
control these guns feel crazy I got a
bad juju and like I could feel the range
a lot more on bad juju as well because I
get like the triple 40s in the god that
wasn't a headshot but if I get the turbo
67s just like it one trigger pull and
they're dead and I was like oh feels
good so it's like there are so there are
times when you go through and it's like
Mayhem mixes it up momentum control
mixes it up and I know they're not all
going to be that way but man like that's
just a random shout out just me playing
yesterday I was like I miss how fun that
game mode feels and I'm glad it's not
completely leaving it will be coming
back some point in season four oh yeah
oh yeah absolutely yeah I mean
these are all things that eventually
they're gonna have to you know evolve
into you know what I'm saying and again
I I still want those sets man because I
feel like
as great as Exotics are they've become a
crutch and if they're not gonna do what
e wants which is I what I really want
which is the whole um being able to put
the what is it the mods the artifact
stuff
in conjunction with the with the Exotics
then also yeah like that needs to happen
so we can utilize some of these under
utilized Exotics but um yeah like I I
want the let's say like you you running
the full you know raid set you know what
I'm saying and it it gives this
intrinsic bonus to make you play a
certain way or add like that definitely
you know what I'm saying needs to be in
the game so this way I'll be honest with
you like what I play
it feels weird when I don't have an
exotic on
me you don't say like it feels weird
like I'm not optimal because I'm not you
know and my thing they should there
should be reward
for having a set
you know and that should have some
intrinsic gameplay changing thing that
should help the player you know I mean
so that that's what I I definitely
definitely want
that's me that's what I'm at
child check on it I was like I will say
for like I'm with like
Oh no just as we were talking about like
Exotics and all those different pieces
and it's just this weird feeling of
Exotics don't even feel exotic anymore
to me to a point and that's like whether
it be and that's like GMD was talking
about like vaulting Exotics and
reworking them and bringing them back
and stuff like that and I was like oh
don't get Cognito started on the
vaulting Exotics thing it's like we'll
get into another discussion it's weird
we talked about it before that Exotics
there's a lot of them that are kind of
trash so aeon
Aeons the bushes get the hell out of
here
yes but yeah like gear sets and when you
said the raid specific perks
if they don't Embrace that there is very
little incentive for armor it looks
different
but that's it I can go get I can go get
my 64 pieced out of armor from Solstice
from lastowish from nightfalls from
wherever
and if I get my 64th out of armor I'm
good for nine months pretty much yeah so
if they don't build in perks for the
like hey if you're wearing the full like
if you wear like three pieces of the new
raid set you're doing five percent more
damage in deep Stone Crypt and if you're
in five pieces you get faster reload
speed on your weapons and like they need
to and we've probably said this a lot
too we're repeating a lot sorry yeah but
it's just like but it's still a problem
because like yeah it's like if you go
through inactivity Reckoning was the
prime example of how not to do it go do
an activity get rewarded for something
else that's so backwards
um but yeah go into deep Stone Crypt
three pieces do something five pieces do
something even if it is just in there
you have incentive to now keep this set
this is another set I want as opposed to
I have my set for the next nine to ten
months and I'm good you're pointing it
down
before you go Jack because I'm gonna
forget this point that's where I thought
we were going with Gambit crime yeah I
thought Gambit Prime was the foundation
of the right direction like okay cool we
got this set even though it looked ugly
shout out to them no shout out no shout
out to the art team on that and I love
your art team but that was not a goal
who did those armors but anyway oh like
I loved it remember you you put on two
spots and you would see the stats Rise
And Then There Were specific roles and
century and all that it was the right
direction you know saying for a mode so
I'm like okay this is their
experimentation they're gonna get now we
find out okay one of the gambits is gone
Prime still stand what's up with the
sets like why are we not bringing them
back and it's just like again same thing
Crucible same thing like if you're gonna
give what is it those ritual armors and
those Deuce they're literally
cosmetic with no function in the
activity yeah so zero I got I got two
two things now I was gonna say one but
now I got two so you point out um my
first question was gonna be do you does
the new upcoming Cosmetic System
mitigate some of these frustrations but
then you just said you know that it that
your problem is they are just cosmetic
my guess is this the reason Bungie
hasn't pushed into it is they looked at
their data and they said oh man you know
not many people are uh not many people
are doing Gambit Prime unique armor it's
like of course we're all sitting here
going because they're ugly but and they
tied it to another activity which is
stupid the way the way they said it only
work in Prime and not regular like they
think right yeah they
stuck in this tiny little baby ball in
the director and you're like what the
hell
yeah it's it's bad at literally
everything like like none of it makes
sense it's all like again I'm saying I
love
bungee in so many ways but that was
noticed yeah yeah exactly yeah it was a
very poorly thought out thing but I
imagine they're looking at their data
and they're going well the data says
people don't know it like faction
rallies right they were like all these
people like please bring back these guns
they look incredible and Bungie was like
well our data shows that nobody did
infection release it's like well faction
rally sucked I mean they weren't fun
they were literally go go into this one
lost sector and drive it like 50 times
you know like conceptually the way the
idea the way the idea played out it was
like okay this is an activity I enjoy
playing so they were like hey you don't
want to do faction rallies it's like no
you need to rework faction rallies they
need to be good and this is the problem
with the armor set so my assumption is
that's probably what happened here is
they went and what's the point people
aren't really chasing these armor sets
where you know and and because again all
those patch notes like I'll go back to
this point all those patch notes that
they got you know it's like people are
doing this for power so they must be
looking and going I guess people just
don't think they're powerful enough it's
like no we think they look like garbage
and we want like if if I got the you
know if I got the uh set from uh I got
that Hunter set with the eyes all over
it from a tangled Shore I love the
Tangled chore set yeah you gave me a
tangled chore set that had really cool
perks I chasing down bro you know right
now I'm chasing it because I still
haven't got a single good rolled helmet
yeah bro with you I'm so would you
detang that there's a warlock set is
like this almost Gladiator style helmet
and then this chain mail sick kind of
thing it's mean and perks are always
horrible when I get it but I'm just like
man I would love this rework with some
cool perks and yeah I'm with you on that
dot big time man like they they they've
got to rework the modes you know what
I'm saying to make it fun and then
people would do it you know saying so
it's just like yeah they I think they
made some which I think what you used to
call it you got a term for it anyway
articles I forgot but um at the end of
the day it I do agree with what exactly
I think what you're saying in reference
to that they they make these weird
judgment calls and think we're not doing
it because of something else when it
really comes down to the acquisition and
the fact it's either not fun or just not
implemented correctly so yeah I I would
I would definitely agree with you on
that
hey you're about to say something I'm
letting you guys go back and forth
I shut up and listen sometimes so it's
fine okay I'm I'm having I'm having fun
but yeah I'm I'm with you on the
I think armor should be really for
builds right
so I think they can change like like I'm
not saying I'm not saying that it
shouldn't be I'm just saying like
I think if I was gonna sit back and
Design This Game I'd be like all right
you can grind for specific sets with
specific perks in specific locations so
if you're like I want this I want to
make this build that's the content you
grind and that's what you do I wouldn't
do the thing like bungee does it's like
no you're grinding too hard or not just
let people do what they want like let
people be self-directed and so scatter
armor sets all around the game so it's
not just like you know oh yeah you get
the global loot pool Everywhere You Go I
want to be like no if you do this
activity you get this this armor if you
get this activity you get this armor you
know oh you really want that raid set
then you gotta grind that race actually
no let's go they could they could bring
Benedict back and be like yeah every
raid actually gives tokens now and so if
you complete one raid this week you
could get loot from anything absolutely
I love that love that that that's kind
of what we're at the machine used to do
it would still incentivize a person for
still running it even if he got the
drops for the week he could yeah based
on the frequency of him running it and
helping other people he still would get
rewarded by mixing those Siva keys so
Benedict could still serve that purpose
to again incentivize keep running I I
completely agree and I love your point
about
specific activity you know specific set
you know it definitely encourages you to
participate definitely I wanna I wanna
like go to Earth and be like well I want
to Duke Mark 44 if I grind to Earth I
get it if I go to Mars I get a
completely different gun you know I want
to be able to chase like that so every
night feels different and then
yeah differentiate like builds come from
you know armor and weapons enhance the
builds but weapons are character so
part of it is you know we're trying to
do like like my ideal destiny
would be I'm working on creating unique
builds I save these sets because I want
different play styles for different
nights you know who I'm playing with
like if I got a two warlock team and I'm
a rogue or a hunter you know I'm gonna
play very differently than if I'm like
with a you know perfectly balanced you
know Titan warlock Hunter team right so
I want like you know different sets of
builds what am I feeling tonight get
that from armor so that I'm chasing it
as much as I want as long as I want and
then
just constantly changing up weapons just
to to max out that Mastery get all the
Cosmetics get all the you know account
upgrades you know things like that so
that I can do whatever I want every
night but there's always a meaningful
and interesting goal to chase rather
than just I don't know do strikes from
you might get a Duke Mark 44 you might
get like you know uh you know any one of
these guns that could drop in the global
pool like Focus the game more you do
that the game will get a lot better look
at that man still on point as usual sir
around
still on point man I would agree
I should probably say something else
about Scout rifles but I'm not gonna
that's just what we're gonna title this
episode
Scout rifles need love rifles definitely
definitely is in the title of this one
uh outside of that though uh shout out
to Bungie of course always doing the
right thing for good people uh they said
next week we have a tribute going live
in the game to honor one of our dear
friends of vicarious Visions who passed
away last year oh Matt helsem uh the
weekly reset will include a director
message that we'll send you to Mars for
a short quest to honor Mr helsem he
worked closely with the teams at both
Bungie and vicarious Visions on various
projects during our partnership we
wanted to memorialize his contributions
to the destiny Universe We wish all his
family friends and everyone that he he
impacted during his life the very best
thank you to everyone in the community
who join us and remember in his warm
Soul so
didn't honestly expect it but a nice
little side quest to honor a guy who
worked on the game and most likely
anybody who he lost he's a game
developer
guaranteed probably way too soon so
shout out to um what Bundy's doing and
then of course our condolences to Mr
holsum's family as well
but I mean other than that to not turn
it into a somber note to finish this
thing up and bring everybody down
um patch notes coming or patch is coming
on the 22nd uh they're gonna do the hot
fix for that one and that's going to
kind of also get Xbox game pass prepped
up we've got Forsaken and Shadow keep
going live so if you got Xbox game pass
you will be you know getting some free
Destiny so even if you haven't played
since D1 forsaken Shadow keep basically
the whole damn game is going to be free
on there go enjoy it the only thing you
won't have is the seasonal content but
you got like six weeks if you play
through everything else you're probably
gonna get a good experience anyway and
see if you want to get ready for Beyond
light that one's cool definitely shot in
the arm I mean you know how I feel about
this
um at the end of the day
this is a fantastic way for people to
get into the the ecosystem I think
they're going to get a tremendous influx
and then come November 10th with the uh
the Next Generation consoles with the
series X you know I'm seeing a lot of
people saying yeah I'll definitely touch
Destiny and but the fact that uh
Microsoft has a little bit of a cycle
over a first party issue at lunch
Destiny becomes super attractive to a
lot of people with a new console so yeah
I'm I'm excited for my Xbox Brothers
they're they're definitely going to be
catching up um Shadow keep and forsaken
it's fantastic content if you have not
there's tons of people have not played
Destiny in so long so to have that free
and Game Pass is going to be a nice bump
and then Crosse works with this right
not yet it's gonna be uh what is it uh I
think next year is going to be platform
across like cross-generational is the
way yeah I'm just gonna gonna be like
Xbox
One base Skies with Xbox series X slash
Series S guys and then
with PlayStation 4 guys but yeah so
they're gonna stay on their platforms
but then the Bungie said next year hope
this is what we get hopefully is when we
get the the integration yeah okay
because I'm you know as a PC player I'm
just thinking you know hey I might check
out be online just with Game Pass you
know I know some of my friends were
thinking about you know maybe coming
back but because they're not you know
happy with the loot thing they might
just want to play the story so they're
just thinking you know we jump through
we run through the campaign real quick
you know yeah but for me it's like Vault
of Glass I want to play I don't know if
I can convince I don't know if I can
convince a whole team you know all my
old guys from D1 to come back for for
vaulted glass so maybe Game Pass will
let us do that bro you know when they
see it all volt the glass Fanboys
because talk with it as soon as they see
it and they add doubt and you know
Bungie gonna have that fly trailer
and they go ahead here the fields is
gonna come in all they're gonna do is
show like fake breaker or something
everyone's going to go crazy dude it's
gonna break the internet they can like
remember to feel remember where you were
when you did XYZ they're gonna show that
you got this product was gonna be going
to Market they gonna have to fly music
we back couple who are we fooling Batman
trailer is gonna be what something
remember the day like depending on
season date starts that thing's gonna be
like the March April timing however they
like date them out that's gonna be like
six months afterwards right halfway
after launch in that Lull in the spring
Vault of Glass is gonna get that big
shot in the arm to give the oh
yeah the 2021 season of unworthy
whatever yeah
with the giant asterisk of plus Vault
plus ball plus ball if they like like I
think you're right because Bungie makes
the hypest trailers of all time but
but it's gonna sound like that artifact
Reveal video if they show champions in
that trailer oh I get used to Champions
listen babe
hey they gotta do something to help
Atheon out man he's not gonna survive
we're gonna jump in the middle we go
guardian's gonna make their own Fate on
one side you're gonna make their fake
another side we're gonna cover the
middle you have a Captain America Titan
with the with the thing shooting through
we're gonna have The Well of Radiance
he's gonna be melted in the first run if
they don't do something
you realize they don't ever have like
Champions and boss fights anyway I don't
know they might have them in the two
portal rooms but when you're in there
definitely
with Florida eyes yeah if they put him
in the Gorgon maze I will like drive to
Luke Smith's house and just just just
drop on my knees and scream why
was one of the best things I ever did in
Destiny one oh that was satisfying
because that thing's terrorize us that
was satisfying I will say I want to do
the jumping puzzle I wanna I go for I
did Nostalgia like he said You Gotta See
How They implement it but the Nostalgia
of just building that spire I gotta open
it I gotta open ever with Fozzie at
fazia you know what to do like I I just
got it that was just wondrous for me
I'll never forget that moment I was like
what I remember just going in Venus on
patrol space I'm like what are these
Guardians doing like I was just let me
call you just passing through and I
didn't know what that was vaulted glass
at the time so I I just you just see
people I'm like why are they here why is
there six people I was so curious how we
get in there yeah well because Venus is
not gonna be in the game and I've never
seen them do like part of the patrol
Zone with like a Sandbox sitting behind
it but What's it gonna be like invisible
walls I'm honestly wondering how we
enter that place because that Patrol
Zone doesn't exist and theoretically
won't
I'm worried they're gonna just be like
hey it's nessus come to nessus we added
a new area to nessus it's a new entrance
because Vex time is no take me back to
Venus it's the only planet I care about
like I got the moon I'm happy that's my
second favorite planet but I need Venus
maybe they dust that bad boy off out of
the Vault they dust it off
maybe Venus is the is the content for
this is not coming that that's one other
planet there's no like
they're taking half the planets away
right like so maybe they are gonna like
drip feed planets in like one at a time
like hey season we got a whole plant
because that would hype people up you
know that would hide people up for this
season we just added a planet people be
like oh my God
but that's usually something they
reserve for expansions
that'd be a big ask yeah is it we all
ask it a lot but this is definitely
Bungie here
it would soften the blow though it would
soften the blow of the whole you know we
took all the planets you gave us money
for away
I I just can't wait though to see that
they I know the trailer is gonna slap
that's really good oh it's going yeah
they got the best trailer team yeah
I want their camera controls dude I want
oh for one I want a screenshot mode that
just like oh yeah
just let me take a clean shot for the
yeah Dusty needs a photo mode but like
but an actual like cinematic mode that
you could turn on just to like get a you
know not even a free roaming camera let
me just have like even a shot but the
free roaming camera would be wonderful
I don't know just there's so much you
could do as this game always looks so
amazing I have like how we doing ghosts
as you see but we sit there out like
half of my gameplay hours is me in photo
mode because I'm in this cool place
cherry blossoms are around me and I got
the hot suit with the poles and like I
just want to do that Desi sometimes you
got that outfit on you in that cool and
the sky boxes oh man it would look great
they have the tools we'll just never get
them yeah definitely I'm definitely for
my Xbox brothers who are definitely
going next gen man y'all get that 60
frames
brother there's no going back I cannot
wait but if they had that Envy of me
that that fast loaded and that 60
friends and I got that old lab now that
snakes to test it out yeah like system
seller differences be like load speed of
going to the tower on like PS4 versus
PS5 people are just gonna be like I
gotta get an extra console for what
Destiny 2. it's a must buy you're like
wait what yeah yo shout out to dizzy in
the crazy he's like you're not welcome
back you left us
man who did it when you you would you
like when you see November 10th you
gonna understand why oh this is why he
was out it's a whole new game brother
that's it you got to come to the VIP
section of the club now you guys talk
I'll be back there's oh that's let's go
let's go
as a uh as a PC player yeah I'm very
uh
I I have the game installed on an SSD
already oh so you're yeah you know what
it is I've when they did the cross save
I booted up and I was like come on this
can't be that bad and uh oh man the guy
who did it make me do who redeemed it
who did I miss damn
e with the perfect fall right now get
ready for the fall getting that uh
incredible cardio in getting this all
the touch of the knob now all week we in
shape y'all look at look at that
professional turn and twist and extra
extension you already know the ABS is
off Fleek right now the boys are shady
eating right you eat right well you can
do that you're eating right
salute yeah man shout out to the chat
yeah they said I left them Hydra yeah
you damn right I left your heart now
y'all got that 30 frame molasses mode I
ain't doing that
driving a Toyota and I got a Roy hey you
understand your Toyota that's your
business but now that y'all up your game
I'll be back
you can't change foreign
I
left you in the projects bro oh my God
hey don't get mad at me cause I moved up
[Music]
all jokes aside it's gonna be fun
November 10th get ready this is a great
deal for um Gamers I love new people
into the ecosystem it's gonna be fun man
hey yo fuzzy
he said question can we get a Channel
please redeemed to make IOP to put your
Geek Easy I mean you spin the points
third yeah you could probably you gotta
talk that out with him but we might have
easy Geek Easy what do we put about
enough I put up enough gym stuff on
Twitter that shit's status I got I got
your tweets of you walking around I
didn't see it any actually live action
boy set up frauded
yo just left the gym cheeseburger over
here there you go yeah so we need to set
up our patreon just to get you to work
out there we go last word patreon there
we go shots fired
what city what up I see you it was a
good show good show today oh man it was
awesome to have you today Doc it's been
an absolute pleasure of course been too
long but glad to have you back in
somehow we never run out of stuff to
talk about that's for sure
Destiny's a big game
always
absolutely
well I was like you got anything else
for the for the day
I mean I'm gonna go play Mario
that's fair I actually care about that
no I mean I'm I'm having a blast I could
you know we could talk for 10 more hours
on Destiny yeah but I don't think people
want to you know if you want me to you
know you want me come back a little bit
sooner a little bit sooner probably uh
probably
be able to Pace out what I'm saying a
little bit better than waiting like what
two years now yeah you did wait it was
like he had a lot to get off his chest
so we just he had to get in the
beginning
Scout rifles
definitely bro but now what would I tell
people what you got going on what could
they find you all that good stuff man
you can find me at uh at Doc Squiddy on
Twitter obviously
um I'm making a game called adios that's
on Steam you should wish list it it's
just a you know short little story based
game uh but you know if I sell about 7
500 copies I get to go live in a cabin
in the woods in Canada for a month which
is what I'm going to do to decompress so
you know please buy as many copies as
possible
it's looking at the work in the Game Dev
World come on yeah gotta buy myself a
gotta buy myself a series X too you know
so I can yeah I can play Destiny on the
the latest and greatest console uh we'll
put the link to adios in there for y'all
man check them check my boy out man yeah
right now
I know it's on Steam is the uh like
that's where we can wish list it it's
just because we're getting it on the
Xbox store so it will be on Xbox two
yeah it'll be day in day they they're
the ones who backed us up I gotta say
people at Xbox they're amazing they're
like kind supportive and very into games
nice like I I was blown away by just how
like amazing the the guys I've been
working with are like they they're legit
like they they're real they're not just
like big business types it's great um so
yeah it'll be an Xbox game um if there
were if it was coming to other consoles
uh the contract would prevent me from
telling you that so
um you know I couldn't say I couldn't
say it but uh
unless unless we like somehow managed to
get like another 20 000 bucks we will be
shipping this year
um awesome that's what's up man yeah
it's it's coming pretty soon but it's
got you know DC Douglas the voice of
Albert Wesker in it so you're pretty
hyped a bunch of people told me uh the
story is really good so that's great
because I worked really hard on that so
you know we'll see but I'm hoping I'm
hoping maybe my next game is a shooter
that's what I want to finally prove to
people like I know what I'm talking
about with Shooters so that's that's
what I'm gonna do next but yeah you're
gonna really get these Scout rifles
there we go yeah
if you want to read my uh my destiny
writing that'll be on medium.com
which was my real name but somebody took
that on Twitter hence doc Squiddy um
yeah 13
000 words on death stranding seven
thousand words and days gone like I get
you your money's worth you know I write
dense stuff I got The Last of Us piece
coming here real soon so nice that one's
probably ginormous
I think it's 2 000 right now but the
last was 2-1 is 7 500 right now
so they're long yeah nice yeah man nice
man good to have you back man at the
campfire definitely one of our
influential guests and it was always a
pleasure man like I said the one of the
greatest articles I still say during the
destiny 2's low point was like I said
your your how it failed its base kind of
thing and it I'll never forget it broke
the net everyone was talking about it I
don't care what nobody say Bungie read
that thing they took it to heart and not
that short after we got a go fast update
so anybody who might go fast y'all
better y'all better send some proceeds
to the man doctor better hook them up
man if Bungie wants to make Destiny
better I still consult on AAA you call
me or come over listen man y'all know
what to do bungee man he's got the ideas
he's definitely got the ideas definitely
passion it's always good to have you
brother
always good to be here you guys are like
the perfect podcast so well appreciate
it oh man thank you there's a lot of
good ones out there so and was
instrumental in choosing the name
remember daddy we had that we was doing
after we was going for Flash boy oh yeah
yeah yeah because you were like uh
you were I remember I said you should
just call it the last word because
that's the you know the gun right and
you were like well I'm worried you know
other people might might be bothered
yeah
yeah I know you're like what 121
episodes in now yeah yep 121 brother
best Destiny podcast on the internet oh
man oh thank you oh man I think you're
rocking appreciate it
a good chance but at least we got a
chance to chop it up at Pax this year it
was good actually it was great seeing
you yeah that was dope thank you for
waiting for me that was cool people told
me like yo someone's here I'm like all
right he's like I was like oh what's up
doc let's go
so it was a pleasure this year before
all the madness of covet obviously at
least that was the last convention I
went to and it was it was really fun
salute to the doc Squiddy my man yeah
hopefully next time I won't need a
wheelchair exactly no but you were there
brother in spirit that was good it was
good to see good to see you and uh
hopefully if if things get back to
normal get Guardian con you got to go to
one man's Destiny if you got to go to
one gcx probably
I'm not sure I'm not sure where I'm
going next yet so we'll see enough
enough
and then uh for me I guess I'm up yep
that's you oh yeah man listen um look
fantastic show you already know more
Cognito on Twitter I love podcast on
Sunday this week Cognito is on vacation
much needed vacation kind of half
business but more vacation you know what
I'm saying so I'll be out there in uh
the state of Washington just relaxing
for a little bit just catching up on
some things and um yeah but uh show the
Lord some love man I will definitely be
checking in on my kids to make sure
they're behaving while I'm gone at the
ILO podcast on Sunday 11 A.M Eastern NFL
football time it's gonna be uh
multi-streamed on YouTube and twitch so
check us out we're gonna have some
probably a guests and um definitely be
talking about all the stuff with a
PlayStation 5 the you know the big
showcase everything that's been going on
in the world and um yeah man it's it's
good he said watch out for the water
orders yeah I gotta watch out for the
fires too but um yeah man so go check
them out that's gonna be fun and again a
salute to everybody body who supports
lordsofgaming.net love what the guys are
doing man we are on open critic and guys
are just they're killing it and gals you
know a nice team and it's just it's
truly inspiring so go check out those
articles please support that it means a
lot to me and um yeah so I know e
probably next week because I'll be away
you know what I'm saying unless
something crazy happens
I think you're actually probably on the
safest week for Destiny to go away
because yeah if you would have been
leaving next week and Destiny would have
launched would you have left
that ain't happening vacation's got to
be worked around you know so this kid
moved out made this trip happen so yeah
because I think this year's gonna be
good actually this this vacation is a
result of me thinking the original
release date was gonna be original
releases like November 22nd though was
it September 22nd right which would have
been next week yeah which I would have
been awesome okay that's what you mean
yeah so I'm like well I got the week off
might as well do something now that uh
Destiny's dad out yeah but yeah that's
what it is man so salute and E what you
got going on man
um yeah just been playing through
Avengers working on trying to get up to
a point where I can kind of
intelligently talk about that
um but yeah working on kind of a project
on the side waiting to see if that one
comes through a little bit of work stuff
going on and then you guys know working
on just like triumphs and tributes and
stuff like that he was real smooth a
project called aside
yet so I was like I'm not going to count
mags until they're like Chicken's still
the hatch or whatever that's all that's
saying it's completely broken cool
um but yeah you guys know but um you
guys know where to find me Twitch
Twitter YouTube it's ebontists
everywhere
um 49 000 Subs to get to 100 so we're
climbing we'll get there eventually so
but thank you guys very much for all the
support this is awesome
obviously we know cognito's gonna be out
next week so no official last word if I
do something else different I may hit it
up on my Discord so if you guys want to
jump in there let me know
um might do something different fun or
just if there's something to talk about
for the 12 I'll just do a video over
that if there's anything major like
ghosts and stuff I'll definitely do a
recap of that one but other than that
man doc it has been a pleasure to have
you today thank you so much for coming
through
um awesome to chat as you said we could
probably talk for many many more hours
about all of the stuff
it's always great it's always great you
guys are you guys like I said the
perfect Destiny podcast it's great thank
you brother it really means a lot much
appreciated well thank you so
for today I think we'll wrap this thing
up obviously we can't still never
knowing how long we're gonna go go
longer than we think it's gonna happen
so uh for episode 121 thank you doc
again for coming out Cognito go follow
this man iron Lords Lords of gaming.net
and for me ebonta is right here uh
September 18th episode 121 it's Ben
the last word